state of emergency is still in effect in
elizabeth city as
protests continue they haven't been too
rowdy like we've seen
in portland or in other cities but there
is
now what appears to be an escalation of
the rhetoric from black lives matter
their famous lawyer is on the scene
saying
that this man was shot in the back of
the head that he was executed
and here we go this might be another
hands up don't shoot for those
aren't familiar that was the big
narrative around ferguson which as many
of you probably know i was on the ground
for these riots
and sure enough it turned out hands up
don't shoot was not true it was rhetoric
it was activism it was propaganda
and we got the same lawyer now showing
up in elizabeth city
we also have another story coming out of
virginia so it seems likely that we're
going to get another summer of
peaceful protests which will leave a
wake of death destruction and chaos as
it goes but
you know the media likes to play things
so we're going to talk about these
stories
we've got other stories in similar areas
we've got this new law in florida
pertaining to censorship which is
massive
this bill passed the florida senate it
might
end wikipedia period because it would
stop
social media companies from banning news
outlets based on their content
so no more fact checking no more
facebook fact checkers no more
suppressing news outlets
number wikipedia saying this certain
outlet is not reliable and this one is
so it'll be interesting joining us today
is lawyer legal analyst andrew branca
you're a use of force expert
would you like to introduce yourself
indeed i am yes attorney ander branca
use of force expert uh
you just angle them like a little bit
down so we can oh sorry about that and
just make sure you're talking into it
all right
all right perfect you wrote quite a you
wrote a lot about the the chauvin trial
yes i cover most of these high profile
cases i covered every minute of the show
from trial literally watched all the
jury selection
all the court proceedings uh covered the
entire thing
is it fair to say you know everything
there is about the michael brown case
the tamir rice case
trayvon martin that would be fair to say
i know as much as anybody else who might
have ever looked at those cases for sure
but you you're an expert as i guess
right you looked all these cases
absolutely interesting
because we've got this story now the fbi
is opening up a civil rights
investigation
the narrative has begun and these things
aren't going to be stopping anytime soon
so we'll get into all that with you
thanks for hanging out we got ian he's
chilling hello everyone ian crossland
over here good to be here thank you
yes and me in the corner pushing buttons
changing the cameras
ladies and gentlemen we have a sponsor
tonight we are extremely excited
in the description below you will see a
link to strongerbonesandlife.com click
that link
and you can get 51 off of biotrust's
ageless multi-collagen
i know something about needing collagen
because i've been skating for decades
and i'm an old man at 35 so i need to
make sure i'm eating healthy and taking
care of myself
so we actually have a bunch of this
stuff ian's always putting in his coffee
yes
when he has coffee i didn't have coffee
today but it's really good it is really
good it makes the smoothies taste like
creamier and more full
and collagen is what you need for your
joints for your fingernails for your
skin
so you really want to be taking this
stuff if you're athletic or just if you
want healthy skin as you're getting
older
check this out we got some amazing stuff
over here so again go to
strongerbonesonlife.com 51
off they say you get a 60 day money back
guarantee
they say for every order today they will
donate a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org to
eight
to date biotrust has provided 4.4
million meals to hungry kids
so please help biotrust hit their goal
of 5 million meals this year
it is non-gmo and free of artificial
colors flavors preservatives and
sweeteners
and free of gluten antibiotics and rbgh
and rbst
no odor or taste unlike bone broth or
other collagen supplements
there's no clumping like other
supplements free shipping with every
order and
free vip live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust team of expert
nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order and a free new
e-report the 14 foods for amazing skin
with
every order this stuff's awesome it's
it's some of the best stuff i've uh in
terms of you know collagen supplements
when we're making smoothies it really
does make it taste like a milkshake it
like makes it thicker and better
so i'm a big fan and i'm extremely
grateful to biotrust for being sponsored
the show
so again in the description below you'll
see the link strongerbonesnlife.com
check it out and don't forget to go to
timcast.com
click the members only but in the top
right you can sign up to get access to
our exclusive
members area we have a bunch of amazing
segments
from our guests we will have a bonus
segment tonight and we'll be talking
about a lot of things
relevant to the black lives matter riots
these cases so you'll definitely want to
check this one out
let's jump into this first story and
we'll just get right into what's
happening with this latest development
cnbc reports fbi opens civil rights
probe into killing of andrew brown jr in
north carolina
the fbi confirmed tuesday that it will
investigate the killing of andrew brown
jr a black man who died after police
shot him during an arrest in north
carolina last week
the announcement comes a day after
attorneys for brown's family
allowed to watch a 20-second video of
his arrest said the 42-year-old was shot
in the back of the head while he had his
hands on his steering wheel
brown was killed wednesday one day after
a jury found derrick chauvin guilty of
the murder of george floyd
whose death in custody reinvigorated the
movement opposing police brutality
against black people we're also seeing
the famous lawyer civil rights attorney
ben crump
he said if they thought andrew brown jr
did something inappropriately
and criminal you all would have seen the
video by now there was no need for them
to be judge jury and executioner
well let's let's talk about what's been
going on because i mean he's got a point
right cops shouldn't be judged during
executioner
well of course they're not all these
cops are subject to
judicial review departmental review
the truth always comes out in these
cases no one's hiding the body camera
footage sometimes there's a procedure
that needs to be followed under state
law for camera footage to be released
to my understanding the department is
moving through that procedure with the
court the local court to get that body
camera footage released
but benjamin crump has a long history of
less than comprehensively sharing
information about these cases in a way
to shade it in a way that's favorable to
him
and what's favorable to him is to get a
very large typically multi-million
dollar settlement out of the city as
quickly as possible
that involves developing a propaganda
tsunami
around these cases that pressures
politicians
to spend other people's money taxpayer
money to make their own
political problems go away and he's
extremely
good at it so you in your opinion that's
that's his game that's what he's doing
do you think he actually cares about
these cases or what
we can't know with this case in
particular because we haven't yet had an
opportunity to look at the entirety of
the evidence but i can tell you he was
involved in the george zimmerman case
and the michael brown case most of these
high profile cases and in those cases
where we have had a chance to look at
the totality of the evidence
you only ever saw half the argument from
benjamin crump the half that made him
wealthy yeah well uh this is the guy who
said
he's the hands up don't you guy right so
so now he's he i remember back during
the ferguson riots
they had this board where they showed a
person and then they drew lines of like
this is where he was shot and this means
that
he's doing the same thing now he's
showing this board and he's you know
drawing a line in the back of the head
right you know look i i hate to say it
because for a while i always wanted to
err on the side of i think most of us do
on those that are victims we want to
we want to make sure we're protecting
the innocent the problem is how many
times
are we gonna get abused by people who
are giving us half the story or just bad
information
and then we end up with riots
massive taxpayer payouts and the story
is not what we thought hands up don't
shoot was not true
right so when that officer when the
grand jury
uh declined to indict the officer in the
michael brown hands up don't
shooting the whole world is shocked how
could they not indict him wasn't
obviously that an unlawful shooting
because they only ever
were shown half the narrative the
narrative that was consistent with an
unlawful shooting but when you look at
all the facts
you learned that michael brown actually
attacked that officer fought him for his
gun
charged him and michael brown was much
much larger than that officer
and the officer's use of force was
appropriate if you knew the totality of
the facts the same with the
trayvon martin george zimmerman trial
the world was shocked that george
zimmerman was acquitted well you would
not be shocked if you'd actually
seen heard all the evidence you're only
surprised if you only saw the evidence
that was the part that benjamin crump
wanted you to see
are you familiar with what's going on
this andrew brown junior case so far i
think this is the gist of it so far
right
i expect we'll see the same pattern
again it's so new
uh that we haven't seen anything like
the totality of the evidence but i see
benjamin crump with the same kind of
placards
uh the same intimations that someone was
shot in the back so therefore it must be
unlawful in fact that's not true there
are many circumstances in which people
are shot in the back
and it's entirely lawful do you know
about that case in atlanta
where i i forgot the guy's name uh the
cops were the guy was sleeping in a
wendy's drive-through he was drunk
the cops arresting him he runs he runs
he took he [ __ ] them took their taser
was running away
turned and pointed the taser back at the
pursuing officer so the cop shoots at
him right and then they said he shot him
as he was running away he shot him in
the back but it
but that's an interesting a point where
you know of course that guy i think he's
still in jail right that cop went to
jail
like he's he's awaiting trial or
something i don't i know he was charged
for sure
i'm not sure if he's out on bail or uh
or currently in jail
you have you have a video where you can
see someone is running away but they can
still turn and aim a weapon behind
themselves
you know and shoot at a cop absolutely
or there's many circumstances where
someone's presenting a threat
to a third person like if i was
threatening to shoot you
and a cop was behind me a cop would be
entirely privileged to shoot me in the
back that mikaya makaya bryan was her
name i think it was right
with the knife she had the situation the
cop shot her and she got hit in the back
not because he was defending himself
because he was defending a third person
so you know here's here's the big issue
when it comes to you know michael brown
when it comes to this guy
uh andrew brown why are the cops showing
up in these neighborhoods where people
clearly don't want them there and
they're seeking to exploit anger in the
community
you know look i understand people call
the cops and people in these communities
call the cops look at jacob blake
this woman called the cop saying i need
help they showed up now that cop gets in
trouble
and nfl players put jacob blake on their
helmets and that guy assaulted that
woman and was nearly going to kidnap her
kids
right the cop tries to save her and he
becomes the bad guy
the unarmed jacob blake with a knife in
his hand yeah right
entering a car full of children prepared
to drive away with them when he's known
to have crashed this woman's prior car
that's why she had this car he wrecked
her prior car and blake said i shouldn't
have grabbed the knife
i'm pretty sure okay it's been a while
since i've gone over that case but i'm
pretty sure he would like later said
like i should have gone for the knife i
should have grabbed it
he conceded when he was interviewed that
he had the knife in his possession
as if it was incontestable i mean you we
have the photographs with him
turning the bumper of the car with the
knife in his hand you know what i think
this is
first it's fair to say there are issues
where we probably would like some
accountability in many circumstances we
don't think we get
right i know you were mentioning before
the show every instance where a cop
unjustly killed someone they've been
held accountable there are circumstances
where people have experienced that
aren't as bad
right where people feel like they're not
getting accountability which i think
lends itself to the bias people have
when they hear these stories
first a lot of people will justly get a
speeding ticket
they'll get angry and they'll say oh the
cops out that was stupid i shouldn't
have got a ticket that's me
right then there are some instances i've
experienced where cops
you know had my fourth amendment right
violated they kicked their kicked their
way into my home my apartment when i was
in my early 20s unjustly and then
realized that oh wrong house and i had
to leave and i've had bad experiences
i think people will see these stories
where there are bad cops
often who get caught and then assume
every single circumstance must be a bad
bad cop because like what you said but
on a bigger scale if this guy crump is
coming out
and only showing one side of the story
everyone assumes the officer must be
guilty
now scale that up people are only seeing
videos and stories where the cop
is doing something wrong or they're
seeing the one side of it and it affects
their entire perspective of all police
everywhere
and now we have 33 percent according to
gallup of people under 35 who think the
police should be abolished
right and by the way the the people who
believe that narrative they're not
stupid people or bad people they
genuinely believe this narrative to be
true
they're acting in good faith they
believe there's a serious problem here
that needs to be addressed
the trouble is their belief isn't based
on reality it's based on propaganda and
because it's not based on reality
the solutions they're espousing can only
make the situation in fact worse
that makes a lot of people rich though
it makes some people very well think
this comes down to uh look you know
you're a use of force expert
and you comment on these cases and i am
a media critic
and i'm always ranking on the media
because it seems like often it
it breaks down to the media is lying to
people
because they make money off it as well
like peaceful protesters right
mostly fiery but mostly peaceful protest
or i love the msnbc guy he's standing in
front of a burning police station
engulfed in flames like
it is peaceful it's p they just torched
the police station dude that's the
opposite
but the media is pandering to an
audience so they're not going to show
you
let me tell you something i worked for a
disney company and i was told
i i asked the president of the company
he said to me
we're going to side with the audience on
these stories so i asked
does that mean if there is a factual
news story which would be offensive to
our audience we don't report it and he
said i think that's fair yes
and that to me shows exactly what we're
seeing now they know what the truth is
now but it might offend our audience so
let's side with them
and give them what they want to hear
it's even worse than that because they
don't just not report on things they
think their audience might find
offensive they
aggressively report on things that can
only be intended to foment hate
and division especially racial division
in the country the modern media in its
current iteration
makes its money from rage and emotion
and hate
because that's what makes people watch
and click and
do all the things that generate their
revenue if they just reported the facts
this is what happened you interpret what
you think the implications that are
they'd be even broker than they are so
what do we have to do put put kids in
philosophy courses when they're like in
kindergarten
teach them to discern fact from fiction
and
to be calm and rational as they approach
these these very serious
stories a little critical thinking
ability would be useful i think
unfortunately i think our current
education system as well as the media
they don't want that no they want the
opposite right they want well the
schools want paying customers who shut
up
right and the media just want someone
who's gonna just follow the narrative
because they can get more clicks they
can sell more subscriptions they can
make more money
and you know i'll tell you i i often
have opinions that the people who watch
so really this
show really disagree with and i often
get messages from people being like how
could you have said that i will not
support you anymore and i'm like i don't
care
like look man if you want if you want to
watch a show where you get
confirmation bias most of you probably
still get that to some degree
but the people who are upset with it
don't want to watch your feet you're
fueling
the exact same problem we're not going
to agree we're not uh don't going to
agree you know
i had uh i don't know if you know who
will chamberlain is he's a lawyer
sure human events i had him here florida
passed that anti-riot
bill signed into law actually i just
wrote about it so
that would make blocking a roadway a
felony i disagree with that
will agree with that and many people in
super chat said tim you're wrong it
should be a felony
i don't think so i think a high-level
misdemeanor makes sense it's non-violent
civil disobedience you're going to get
arrested in charge of the crime for it
but felonies pretty pretty tough well
one of the things i like about you tim
is that we may not agree on everything
but at least i always know you're coming
from a principled
position we don't happen to agree on
this uh
because i think it needs to be and i
think we'll say said this on your show
the reason they've escalated the penalty
is because the lesser penalty there was
in place was not solving the problem
the problem is these people by blocking
the roads are effectively
making unlawful arrests of everybody in
all those vehicles they're endangering
public safety by making it impossible
for emergency vehicles to get through it
can't be permitted to happen
and if a misdemeanor was enough to
dissuade the behavior i'd be perfectly
fine
the da's aren't prosecuting they're just
letting them go that's a separate
question the governor and the
legislature only have so much power they
can only do what they can do then it's
up to the people to elect prosecutors
that will
execute on that law the way the people
who elect prosecutors want it executed
that's that's that's that's that's the
big problem i guess you know i look at
it from
if we prosecute someone on a mismeter
charge they can get to a year in jail
right
i mean that one theory but if they keep
doing it certainly at a certain point
it's going to be like okay now you're
you're in for a year they're not
currently subject to any prosecution
because the prosecutors are dropping all
charges so there's an effect
no criminal liability for the conduct so
that that was my point i mean
you can make the law whatever you want
the prosecutors won't prosecute i i
worry now by making it a felony the
prosecutors might be like ah that's a
bit too harsh to charge them with a
felony so i won't do it
and they may but the prosecutors were
talking about are really politically
motivated prosecutors anyway so they
they're on the side of the protesters
that's their team
they're not going to do anything to harm
their team right there's no bail
requirements if there's bail it's
dismissed if there's charges they're
dismissed
often the people who were arrested for
these protests are out of jail before
the officer who arrested them is done
doing the paperwork for the report
there was a woman i think like in
portland charged with felonies they just
cut her loose
then she goes back and she like that's
fire to the police station yeah one part
of the florida law was a provision that
says hey if you're arrested on this
charge
you can't get released on bail until
you're at least put in front of a
magistrate which is the normal process
so you can't do this
catch and release the cop basically has
to write you a summons and let you go
because when he lets him go
they go right back to obstructing the
road again i mean let me
let me ask you about the chauvin trial
so you you wrote a lot about it i was
following your writing during the
chauvin trial and
the media was only giving us one side of
the story it was it was remarkable when
i'd go to nbc
and they'd be talking about what the
state prosecutor you know the
prosecutor's witness said this this and
this
and they were all really great for the
prosecutor right and then on cross when
the defense
actually challenged these ideas and did
great did great
they would they would say nothing so
sure enough you mentioned
uh earlier that a lot of people begin to
expect a conviction like or at least an
indictment with with darren wilson in
ferguson
people were shocked when this guy was
not charged with anything it's because
the media wasn't giving him the truth
however over a long enough period of
time with propaganda and manipulation
and riots
this time not only did they get their
indictment they got a conviction on
all charges so not only is the media
giving a false view of things
but now it seems to be working right so
by the way a little inside baseball that
whole
darren wilson case with michael brown uh
the reason he didn't get indicted was
the prosecutor there
made the decision to show the grand jury
both sides of the argument the facts in
favor of
guilt misconduct by the officer and the
facts that mitigate that made it look
appear to be a justifiable use of force
and he let the grand jury make the
decision he had no obligation to do that
he could have only offered the half of
the story that would have gotten the
officer indicted
but he offered both sides grand jury
looked at it said nope looks like a
justified use of force to us
you know what happened to our prosecutor
next election he had a soros backed
candidate who defeated him
as prosecutor and that guy ran in part
the competitor
uh ran apart on immediately reopening
the michael brown case
so he did it is that happening yeah he
reopened it looked at it for three weeks
close it again immediately because
there's simply no evidence consistent
with the officer having done anything
wrong
but he won the election so he's now in
that seat he
won political power through this
propagandistic narrative i don't know
how you solve that problem man
well people need to people need to know
who their prosecutor is i bet nobody at
this table knows who the local
prosecutor is here
because normal people don't know right
you need to know you need to care these
are enormously powerful positions and
they're
cheap to buy most prosecutorial races
involve a few thousand dollars
so someone's willing to come in and drop
fifty thousand dollars in a process he
just bought that seat
well so so there has been a wave of
progressive or leftist da's
we just had a story and this one's gonna
get in trouble on youtube but the uh
what's
what's the guy's name chesa bowden you
know this guy in san francisco
he's a progressive prosecutor and he had
a domestic abuser arrested twice and he
cut him loose twice saying oh but the
wife won't
you know won't uh file charges against
him right even though in california
domestic violence is a charge from the
state this it's it's
you're victimizing the state in this
case and i do that because of course the
victim who's being beaten by you isn't
going to
speak out well after got released twice
he went back home and he murdered a
seven-year-old baby
so this is what happens when you get i
don't want to draw a direct one-to-one
correlation between him being this like
new woke d.a
and releasing this guy but it is
consistent with what we've seen
from these leftist prosecutors who are
like i'm going to let this guy go
well you don't get less crime by letting
all the bad guys you've arrested
immediately out of prison
this is the same prosecutor who told his
assistant das
don't argue three strikes under florida
law for any of these people that
that are being brought into court
pretend three strikes doesn't exist now
reasonable people can agree or disagree
about whether they think three strikes
is good public policy or not
but here the prosecutors under him
actually went to court
to fight his order and maybe they don't
agree with three strikes themselves but
it would be unlawful under state law for
them to do what
he was telling his prosecutors to act
unlawfully
in arguing their cases in court and they
weren't willing to accept that legal
liability well who was the prosecutor in
the uh derrick chauvin trial
well they had a whole password i'm sorry
who uh who was the one who
basically initiated the charges i don't
know who would have initiated it they
had
they had at least four prosecutors in
court themselves oh keith ellison the
state attorney general
right um well what happened in that case
was the local prosecutor didn't want
anything to do with the case basically
and handed it off to the state so the
state would take responsibility which
keith ellison was happy to do
yeah and of course he then brought in a
whole panel of prosecutors only
two of whom were actual state
prosecutors uh
of the 10 or 12 attorneys admitted to
prosecute that case
only two were state prosecutors all the
others were private attorneys
from from very high-end law firms who
volunteered to work for free
to prosecute their how is that legal
how's that allowed they're he's
permitted to bring in anybody he wants
that the court will accept
as an attorney for that case and the
court's generally willing to accept
and these are all excellent attorneys
they're all very very good attorneys
but it's it was a gross mismatch between
these 10 or 12 prosecutors
working on the state side and one
frankly
run-of-the-mill defense attorney
perfectly nice guy perfectly capable
attorney but nothing special
working for the defense is there
anything in modern history
that would reflect like is similar to
what we saw with chauvin meaning
the state brings in prestigious
prosecutors
they that the city settles with the
floyd family during the
during the trial have you ever seen
anything no i've not
and it's extremely unusual to especially
during jury selection there's no point
then
to rush to a settlement you may as well
wait and see if
criminal liability has been found uh do
a settlement after the fact if they'd
settled very quickly after the event i
wouldn't have been surprised
but to wait as long as they did to jury
selection and then suddenly
rushed to settlement knowing the biasing
effect and maybe that's why it was done
knowing the biasing effect that it would
have uh and i've never seen the case in
which the large majority of the quote
unquote prosecutors on the case
were actually private attorneys who were
brought in as a kind of
hit team that seems crazy to me but you
know seems crazy to me after that is who
in their right mind
would stay in minnesota i mean the state
i mean keith ellison's the ag right so
this is statewide that means if you're a
cop
anywhere in minnesota right and you do
anything to save someone else or protect
yourself
you're going to prison and this is
increasingly common this is a pattern
now where
people might think hey i don't live in
the city it's safe where i live i live
out in the country it's a nice safe
community i know who my prosecutor is i
see him at the
grocery store every once in a while he's
a nice guy i'm sure he wouldn't
prosecute me
but what often happens is a local
prosecutor gets removed
from the decision-making process and it
gets handed off to a chosen prosecutor
from a different district
that happened in the george zimmerman
trial the local prosecutor
to him it was so clearly self-defense he
he quit his job rather than bring
charges against george zimmerman
and they just brought in deborah nelson
from a different part of florida to be
the prosecutor in that case or you see
the case handed off to a state-level
prosecutor
like with keith ellison in the chauvin
trial or with the ahmad arbury case in
in georgia you have a prosecutor local
prosecutor looks at it
i don't want to bring charges here
second prosecutor i don't want to bring
charges third prosecutor
i don't want anything to do with it and
they hand it off to a prosecutor from
another part of the state
why why are they handing it off because
it's a political hot potato everybody
knows what benjamin crump is going to
turn the case into they don't want any
part of it
maybe they should grow some spines or
maybe the
they they're they feel the political
pressure they're going to face is simply
going to be overwhelming for someone who
spent fifteen hundred dollars to become
a local prosecutor
fifteen hundred dollars it's amazing
it's kind of scary that it's that cheap
to buy one of these one of these
positions
yeah you me you make a good point with
the michael brown thing where the
prosecutor got
he ousted and they brought his job lost
his job
so it seems like even if they do grow
spine and say get away from me they'll
just lose their job and they'll bring in
somebody else
that's what happens man propaganda is is
is taking over and
i gotta say it's making me pretty
pessimistic
you know i try to be optimistic a little
bit sometimes i'm i am fairly
pessimistic
which is a problem but uh you know we've
had some we've had some uh
you know james carville comes out says
this is a problem there there are some
signs that maybe we're starting to see
people realize the problem of the
these narratives but then i hear this
stuff and it's been ongoing for like a
decade
and the chauvin trial was the worst of
the worst where
i mean when i i think it was the la the
lapd use of force expert i think it was
was it was it him who said sergeant
steiger for the for the state
was he the guy who said that chauvin was
entitled to use a taser and chose not to
yeah he absolutely was because of course
taser is non-deadly force
so how do you convince a jury that
chauvin was intending to assault or
injure floyd when he de-escalated he
used a lesser force option and even
called ems
because that wasn't really the question
that the jury was being
asked to answer the question was not how
do we decide this case on the legal
merits the question was
do we want to convict this guy and all
go home and live a quiet life or do we
want to
acquit on any one of these charges and
be burned alive in our homes
the woman uh one of the one of the
jurors she didn't know she was an
alternate and i'm sure you saw this
said i didn't want to go through the
riots and the destruction again and i
was worried someone would come to my
house and retaliate
right and you can hardly blame her
because the threat of violence is real
there's a reason they had national
guardsmen outside the courthouse there
was barbed wire the jurors were escorted
to the courtroom by
state police with machine guns this is
not because the
the threat of violence is famous that
machine guns like you mean it
well you know your guns yeah the state
police are would be armed with mp5s or
something equivalent so the actual
select fire right yeah
sure they're not law enforcement doesn't
doesn't
buy semi automatically right right right
there's no restriction on them having
full auto so
great they're allowed to have weapons of
war i suppose that's you know sure
it's it's awesome and the jurors of
course are going to and from the
courthouse
every day during this trial past the
national guardsmen the barbed wire
they know that stuff exists for a reason
they were told by the judge
look we'll try to keep your identity
secret while you're in court which is
nonsense because all these people
disappeared from their normal jobs for
three weeks at a time right so
everyone in their circle social circle
knows that they're not gone they're not
there for a reason
uh and they know eventually the judge
told them we will release your names to
the public
yeah and it's not going to be a good
outcome from
i mean the the defense uh use of force
expert had
blood and a pig's head left at his
former home
uh that wasn't intended to intimidate
him or change his testimony his
testimony was over
right it was for the jurors right it was
the benefit and by the way this applies
also
to every prospective juror witness
expert for any of these future trials
coming up the written house trial coming
up the mccloskey trial coming up the
ahmad arbury trial coming up
all those people also everyone going
through jury selection there
knows what to anticipate now
let me uh pull up a story real quick
because there's something that you're
you're getting me uh
here we go it's bbc
ladies and gentlemen we have this story
from the bbc
anger as ex-generals warn of deadly
civil war in france
now the reasons they're giving for why
they think france will descend into
civil wars is a bit different
they're talking about you know what they
call no-go zones in french neighborhoods
but in an open letter to the president
they mentioned that this leftist dogma
is going to result in their country
descending into civil war
now we're not france i understand that
but seeing this story
and then hearing what you just said
we're talking about
the chauvin trial the the pig's head and
blood left at someone's home
the riots and the threats from maxine
waters we have federal politicians
saying
unless we get mob justice
we will riot more right how can there be
confidence in this government in our
country similar to what i'm you know
it's not one for one with what the
french generals were saying
but with this leftist dogma it seems
like their their moral framework is
there is no truth but power and might
makes right that's what they believe
why would any um you know individual in
this country who believes in the america
american moral framework and it's until
proven guilty
just sit by and let this happen now i
understand for the time being they are
they are after everything we saw in
minnesota there are still people who
would believe or ignore
you know what's happening they would
believe the lies or ignore what's
happening in the state
but for those of us that are paying
attention it's getting it's getting
terrifying
because this is look there's an argument
in my opinion based on everything i've
read maybe manslaughter i don't know
what's your opinion on the show then
maybe manslaughter
well i think there was reasonable doubt
on every one of them charges yeah that
doesn't mean he didn't do something
wrong
uh it doesn't even mean you know it
could be probably true that he committed
a crime
but that's not the legal standard the
legal standard is it has to be proven
beyond a reasonable doubt and i did not
see that here
i i agree um i guess what i'm trying to
say is if someone told me
that based on everything that was
presented to the jurors the jurors
found you know maybe manslaughter i'd be
like that makes sense i guess
i wouldn't you know i might not agree
with that but it's
guilty on all accounts second degree
murder i watched we watched hours of
deliberations with an hour
this is a case in which there were over
55 55 000
exhibits of evidence in which there was
sufficient video that individual expert
witnesses said they spent 100 to 150
hours
reviewing the video evidence and the
jurors went into deliberations and
less than 10 hours later came back with
a verdict that that wasn't due
deliberation and argument over
the evidence in that case and whether it
met the legal standard that was people
who were terrorized and i think the
public looks at this
look first of all you have to you'd have
to accept that a jury that effectively
has a gun to its head
is anything like any model of justice
any of us would want for ourselves or a
loved one because that's effectively
what happened in this case
but first people would have to recognize
that that's what happened and second of
all even if they did recognize that this
was a gross injustice and by the way
it's a gross injustice regardless of the
verdict so
chauvin could have been convicted in a
fair process and justice in america is
not supposed to be about the outcome
it's supposed to be about a just process
if we trust the process we accept the
outcome regardless of what it might be
but if the process is inherently corrupt
you don't get anything like
justice out the other end so first you
have to recognize that the process
is corrupt but even if you do recognize
that well what's an individual person
supposed to do about it
except hope that when they're swimming
in the water the shark doesn't happen to
come for them
so this is this is this is where i'm
getting freaked out right seeing
this story out of france i saw this the
other day i i covered it a little bit
and you know there were some some
political leaders
in the country who said that leftist
ideology on
race and gender is destroying france and
they need to stop it
now they're to the point where their
former generals are warning macron of
civil war
and we've seen many similar articles in
the united states from prominent
publications talking about the prospect
of civil war in this country
i know a lot of people on the left like
to laugh about it but it's not a reality
but
then maybe january 6 might change their
minds
when you see what happens with chauvin
and based on the things you're telling
me where
pigs a pig's head and blood at the home
of one of the witnesses who had already
testified us a message to the jury
a democrat a federal politician who
straight up threatened more violence
she didn't say the word violence had
more confrontation as they're already
rioting
and in the context of violence right in
the context of there's only one way to
interpret it of a year of riots
right and now we have we have the other
remaining officers in the chauvin trial
who are
their trial set for august i believe we
also have kyle rittenhouse
now we have this elizabeth city case now
we have a virginia case
it not only are these instances going to
keep happening because
sometimes cops use lethal force whether
justified or not it's going to keep
happening
it will be weaponized by hard left
cultists people who believe that might
makes right and they can do whatever
they want
and then there's not going to be a
system of justice for anyone involved
cops are already resigning in mass
across the country and have been
since since last year and it's getting
worse even in the area we're in right
now a local town
is facing a shortage of police and they
don't know what to do about it so at
what point do people just say i have no
faith in this system anymore
and do we just see people
taking up arms in their own
neighborhoods rejecting
the law i mean how how does a regular
person
function in a society that has thrown
out the rule of law
well mostly you just hope it doesn't
happen to you mostly you just hope that
you don't get targeted that's the
that's the only thing you can hope for
the solution is certainly not
private justice uh that just makes you
even more vulnerable to successful
prosecution than if you had the
background and training and badge and
apparent authority of a police officer
you're not less vulnerable
to this kind of prosecution you're more
likely to make mistakes you're more
likely to be mischaracterized look at
the guys in the ahmad arbury case who
are making
what was almost certainly a lawful
citizen's arrest under georgia law you
may not like the georgia citizens arrest
law i get that reasonable people can
disagree
but if you read the law they almost
certainly met the conditions for making
a lawful citizen's arrest a varberry
and they're not being treated like cops
they're just being treated as people who
wanted to be cops and murdered a black
man for driving through a neighborhood
uh so i don't think private details are
relevant yeah i remember when i covered
that
and there's i believe there's
surveillance footage of him entering
this this this private property
and i had these people on the left they
don't care it's it's they believe
there's no truth but power and they
believe might makes right
so when i come out and say like oh
there's a video the guy was trespassing
i mean
in west virginia you're allowed i'm
pretty sure i could be wrong so fact
check me on this one but i'm pretty sure
you're allowed to shoot someone to stop
them from entering your property
you don't even have to wait until they
get on your property you can prevent
them from accessing your property
well in most states if someone's
attempting to forcibly and unlawfully
enter your dwelling your place of
business your occupied vehicle
there's a legal presumption they're
doing it to cause you deadly bodily harm
which would justify your use of deadly
defensive force not in new jersey
new jersey you have to run away i don't
know where you run to when you're in
your home and you have to retreat from
your own home i guess
if you're sitting in your in your in
your bed in your underwear and someone
breaks in your house
go stand in an alley somewhere in your
underwear i guess and pray for the best
but that's that's the law in some of
these places it's it's
unfortunate when that happens in the
unfortunately i certainly hope there is
not a civil war i mean when we had a
civil war last time i believe that the
death count was something like 600
000 and that's just combat deaths that's
not it doesn't even count people
who starved and suffered other
catastrophes uh a civil war in america
it would easily
be 60 million people but it wouldn't
ended up dying especially in the
just-in-time economy in which we live
and where your grocery store in two days
if it's not resupplied is completely out
of food as we learned during the the
coveted
right but but i'll clarify this point
you know because
i it's been a minute since we've talked
about civil war here on the show but we
we talk about it uh decently amount in
in the context of the escalation of
violence i can't remember which guest
this was but they made a really great
point
you know i often say that when people
look at civil war in the united states
the potential for it and there's there's
a princeton a professor who said we're
in a cold civil war this is not
something i just made up
there you saw this i agree we are in a
cold civil war my concern would be if it
goes hot
so here's here's the issue is that
people imagine the american civil war as
how civil wars work that's not true most
civil wars do not function this way
where you have states seceding and then
two factions
fighting you know right each other that
can't happen anymore not the way we're
structured but right absolutely but even
other countries where there's been civil
war
it's a bunch of different pockets rise
up and there's violence
for against local government against
different factions we had someone on the
show i can't remember who it was but
they said
what happens in america will look more
like syria yes you'll have 30 or 40
factions
you'll have different you know elements
of the government and everyone would be
fighting in in different places for
different reasons
it's not going to be structure it's just
going to be violence and chaos
and it's going to be you know different
in different areas
and i think that's that seems to be a
likely scenario right now
especially based on what we're seeing in
minnesota it may be likely i mean i
certainly hope it doesn't happen for all
the reasons i just described i think the
death toll would be unimaginable
but there's really only three options
right there's reconciliation between the
left and the right
there's civil war or there's subjugation
of the right by the left so which of
those outcomes are we going to pick i
don't see reconciliation anywhere in our
future
i'd like to think there's not going to
be a civil war but i certainly wouldn't
be happy about the third outcome which
would be
effective subjugation of forty nine
percent of pop well
subjugation is happening i mean when i
see these cops
in after everything you've just told me
about the chauvin case
uh and and the the way you presented i
mean people being brought in under armed
guard with cops machine guns
pigs blood all that stuff i can't
believe there are still police officers
who would wear that badge
because they are representing a city
that knows what they did a judicial
system that knows what they did
and they're effectively supporting it by
doing so well they're not really staying
though
so minneapolis pd has lost something
like 20 of its officers in the last year
those you can't just apply that 20
generally because there's huge chunks of
the police force that are not
interacting with the public like
street cops they're at the academy
they're in the headquarters
those people are not leaving they're not
in danger of being derek chovin because
they're not going hands-on with suspects
so they say 20 of the total police force
is leaving
that has to be forty to fifty percent or
more of the street cop
guys are not going to get replaced by
better quality officers they're gonna
get replaced
by people like some of the cops involved
in the
arrest people it's their fourth or third
call out on the street
when suddenly they find themselves in a
george floyd event
so they're more like calls right they
make worse use of forced calls we're
going to see
more cases in which cops are using force
inappropriately and by the way i don't
want to suggest anybody that i think
cops always use force appropriately
there's many cases where they use force
inappropriately but my observation based
on my experience is when that happens
they are held accountable
so what i object to is this notion that
cops are rampantly going around
using force inappropriately and just
society's just letting them do that
that's not true right what's surprising
to me is
well before i get to that the rookie
cops more likely to get killed
and more likely to kill right yes
absolutely bad use of forced calls
less experienced poorer judgment because
of that lack of experience
those are the guys more likely to
accidentally go to the gun when they
meant to go to the taser
and you end up with more force being
used inappropriately you don't get
better outcomes by having a less
experienced police force so this is only
going to exacerbate the problem
it's going to keep happening right then
you're going to get more of these
lawyers coming out saying oh these cops
did wrong see this is proof we got to
abolish the police
this is why i'm surprised who in their
right mind would sign up to be a police
officer right now i don't think anybody
is
well they have rookies they they they
have people coming and joining the
forces people people
desperate for the job who don't
understand the risks or who believe that
hey
it won't happen to me i just have to be
right because most most
officers are not involved in a george
floyd type of case
but of course it's not up to the cop i
mean one thing most people
i don't think they realize it's not
really the cop
who decides how much force to use in an
encounter with a violently non-compliant
suspect
it's the suspect who determines how much
force is going to be used
so it's not really within the cops
control unless the cop decides
i'm not going to engage i'm not going to
go hands-on i'm just going to let this
person go
and whose interests is that in i mean
it's cities where the police have long
adopted that kind of approach
that have become the high crime hell
holes and not for people who live in
rich suburbs but for the people who live
are caught captured trapped in those
urban
centers and violence who by the way when
they're asked they want more police
they don't want the police defunded
however we've seen from gallup that many
people in these places
do say they want more cops but i don't
see them coming out to support the
police i don't see them going to
fundraisers i don't see them marching in
the streets
so the way the way i see it is you can
tell me you want something
but if you've got people setting fires
to buildings destroying them completely
beating people in the streets smashing
windows
that's the voice being heard in the
press and you won't even stand up
outside with a sign
you've abstained from the vote right you
have to put your your vote where your
mouth is and if you don't do that
nothing changes but in fact nothing
changes i mean just look at the school
systems in these same places
those school boards are elected by the
residents in those communities
and they continue to elect people who
don't educate their children so
indoctrinate their children what are we
supposed to make of that again they
don't put their votes where they say
their mouth is so we've seen a massive
escalation in violent crime
across the country we've seen shootings
skyrocketing i think new york it's like
what 250 percent or something ridiculous
275 some ridiculously large number
cops are at a point now where i'm we've
already seen many resign i think in
albuquerque recently
20 officers resigned from their
emergency response team so no more riot
riot control
they're going to bring in rookies cadets
to be trained though that'll go well
so we're going to get more of these
instances but we're also going to hear
more of cops saying i'm not going to
either i'm going to quit the job and go
somewhere else i've gotten those emails
or we're going to see cops who just say
i won't respond to that call
gun violence and crime will continue to
skyrocket in places like new york
chicago and i believe la
obviously the big cities and then what
happens when someone finally says
i'm going to fight back or i'm going to
form my own neighborhood watch group and
we're going to take up arms
now you see the emergence of urban
factions
opposing uncontrollable violence yeah
that's that's that's the seed for some
serious urban conflict i understand the
the drivers that would lead people to
want to protect their own communities
their homes by forming these private
little cooperative groups
uh the legal jeopardy they're creating
for themselves is unbelievable because
if something goes bad if they are then
involved in some kind of george
floyd-like event the prosecutors will
characterize it as a conspiracy
among the group each and every one of
them will be equally responsible for the
worst conduct of any of their members so
if it turns out there's some
lunatic in your group that you didn't
realize was a lunatic until he got a
chance to point a gun at somebody and he
murdered someone straight out murder
someone
if you're deemed a co-conspirator you
committed that murder my friend
so let's let's uh let's keep going with
this logic all right so first we already
have the dramatic escalation and violent
crime across the city
across our cities police resigning or
blue flu or
refusing to answer calls retire on the
job we have arrived
a mass wave of retirements from tons of
there was a story in
in uh uh out of new york a 30 year old
female cop retired he's 30. she was
there for seven years and she's like i'm
retiring as a police officer at 30. when
i say retire on the job i mean these
these are people at least if a cop just
outright retires you know he's not there
anymore he's not a resource he needs to
be replaced
retire on the job is when they don't
leave the job they just stop doing the
job
right they stop going to the calls or
they delay going long enough so when
they get there it's just time to do the
chalk line and there's no danger anymore
so let's follow this logic all right so
so
more crime it is happening we've already
seen videos
of people pulling guns on protesters and
rioters we had mccloskey's very famous
case
there's also a viral video where i think
there's a couple of guys and a few women
were standing at their
their street the entrance to their block
holding a couple rifles
so we're already getting close to that
point so let's say the prosecutor
let's say rioters are rampaging through
an area
someone uh well this has actually
happened right so kyle rittenhouse
comes out and says i'm gonna defend this
this area
i'm gonna stop the riots what people
need to understand about the riots in
kenosha is that
it was several nights of ongoing rioting
you had i think was a 78 year old man
was was i don't know i think he was 78
his building was on fire
he was trying to stop the people
ransacking his store and when he went up
to stop them someone bashed him over the
back of the head with a rock
then you get someone a group of people
who come out then you get kyle
rittenhouse
and then the media demonizes him they
continue this pressure campaign
what's the next step after we've already
seen this and it's only getting worse
at a certain point there's going to be
more groups like like
like the guys with kyle right now
emerging there's going to be more
uh people doing this across the country
you're going to get more prosecutors
i i tweeted i think kyle right now will
get life i'm exaggerating because i
don't know if life is even an option
based on what happened
but i think they're going to it's going
to be like chauvin it would be life
it'll be like okay we'll charge you two
counts of murder so there would be life
in prison without possibility of early
release
and i've looked at every minute of that
all the video available on written house
i've written about it
extensively can i mention my website i
can't remember i did that
uh if folks want to see what i write
about these cases it's law of self
defense dot com that's all you need to
know law of self defense dot com
and i've looked at every bit of
available video i've done in-depth
analysis based on wisconsin law of that
case just like i would do if i was
retained to consult on the case
that was lawful self-defense every day
of the week and twice on sunday there's
no question about it
the difficulty the reason he's finding
himself charged in this predicament and
this happens a lot in these cases is
that with the best of intentions
he put himself in an environment likely
to turn violent he he appears as if he
went to the fight as opposed to the
fight coming to you
the same issue with the mccloskeys they
went out of their house
to confront the protesters if they'd
stayed in their house and a protester
tried to come into their house
they would have been good to go 100 but
when
it appears or could be made to appear
that you went to the fight rather than
the fight coming to you
it begins not to look like self-defense
even if technically
on what the law allows it's entirely
legitimate use of force
uh i don't i don't know if you can
answer this but uh i'll ask anyway and
if you can't just feel free say so but
do you think retin house is gonna get
life again it's one of these situations
much like the chauvin trial where you
have to ask yourself
is this case actually being decided on
the legal merits
on the legal merits it looks to me like
self-defense 100 percent
all three events uh he was involved in
but if it's not being judged on the
legal merits then it's just a political
witch trial
essentially uh and then the outcome is
all depending on
well the political dynamics the
propagandizing around it and of course
people are not getting both sides of the
story again
let me ask you a bit about this case i
don't know if you're able to opine
uh more on the written house stuff but
you you know uh
so two people died a third person had
his his i believe his right bicep was
was blown off
uh you just said that it was
self-defense every day of the week and
twice on sunday right
if he used more force against that last
person would that have been justified
against the person shot in the arm yeah
yeah so well you're privileged to use
force
as long as necessary to neutralize the
deadly force threat against
you once that deadly force threat is
neutralized you're not privileged to use
force anymore
so to the extent the person could no
longer constitute a deadly force threat
then written house would not be
privileged to use force anymore by the
way would he
but would he know that right so the
issue is this guy had a gun and it's it
all
is a factor of his reasonable
perceptions
um so it's quite possible by the way in
the written house case
there's cases we call awful but lawful
where both parties could believe they're
justified in what they're doing
so the two guys who are chasing written
house down the street they may have
legitimately believed that they were
chasing someone who just committed a
murder of the first guy in the parking
lot
right they could have believed that that
doesn't make rittenhouse's use of
defensive force unlawful because his
conduct is judged by his
reasonable perceptions if he believes he
just defended himself against gun
guy number one and now he's being
further attacked by guys two and three
well he's privileged to defend
themselves himself
against the reasonably apparent threat
those people present
so i i guess the way i i was looking at
it is you know it was a we had a
conversation before the show
this third guy um i forget his name he's
got a gun he had a he had i probably had
a nine millimeter do you know what kind
of weapon it was i'm not sure
a handgun of some kind i'm not sure and
he tried to take he tried to grab the
gun
from rittenhouse who then fired once
right right
house then backs off
am i wrong in saying that in that moment
if it were you you could have fired at
the guy again
if he still had the gun and appeared in
a position to use it then it's he's
still a deadly force threat i mean
the person's attacking you with the gun
and they say they're like a gun and
there were still gunshots going off
apparently i think i could be wrong it's
been a while since we covered this but
even after he he shot the guy then he
gets up and he looks around and then
just turns around and calmly starts
walking back i was surprised at his
demeanor
it felt like he had written house's
demeanor written house's demeanor
yeah of course it's hard to know what's
going on in his mind but of course he
saw the police right at the end of the
street right so he was running
to safety it appeared that he
neutralized his attacker so now he was
able to proceed to safety i mean he
didn't run and hide
right he ran and presented themselves to
the cops which is
not the conduct of someone who's just
committed murder i guess what i'm saying
is that it feels like
um he he a lot of people have said that
he was in control he was you know very
much like
he he he knew where to like
he de-escalated essentially right i
guess what i'm trying to say is if
somebody was sitting in front of me with
a nine millimeter in their hand
i'm not just going to like calmly back
away as they're standing there
still holding the gun and he did
yeah again it's difficult to know what's
in its mind i mean we make as human
beings we make
we do we tend to engage in a lot of mind
reading from a person's demeanor we
ask ourselves hey if i was in that
situation would i act the same way
or if i were acting that way what would
that tell me about my own internal
thought processes
but it's very dangerous to do that
especially in the context of violent
confrontations most of us are not in
violent confrontations most of us
haven't been in a fight since junior
high school or wherever
it really affects how your the way your
mind
captures and stores and processes
information and makes decisions
under stress especially life-threatening
stress is completely different than the
normal experience so
even written house if you'd asked them
ahead of time if you'd shown them that
video of someone
else involved in that would have said oh
i never would have acted that way but
you don't know until you're actually in
a situation well that's that's one of
the jokes we've seen in the mikaya
bryant case
it's mikhail bryan i'm getting a name
right right is that i believe that's
correct
okay so uh seeing people saying like why
didn't he shoot the knife out of her
hand
as have you seen that people actually
tweeted this as if
in a split second when someone draws the
knife and you have
a tenth of a second to make the decision
you could aim for the hand and
lead the target as the knife is moving
forward to hit just the knife and not
the person behind the knife right
this is what people think he had nine
seconds to decide what he was going to
do that instance he got out of his car
right this was already underway
nine seconds between figuring out
there's a reason every law enforcement
officer in the country everyone who
takes a self-defense course for using a
gun is taught to shoot center
mass on the threat because you need
those rounds to hit the actual threat
not hit
innocent people downrange of the actual
threat
um and and by the way it's unfortunately
like jurors won't know that right we
might know that we've taken a
self-defense course
uh but most jurors don't know anything
about self-defense they might think it's
perfectly reasonable to try to shoot a
knife out of someone's hands it's one of
the reasons i tell
people there's no way just like in a
physical fight i don't care what your
training is your martial arts skills how
good you are with a gun or a knife or
whatever there's no way to reduce
the risk of the physical fight to zero
you can get it low
if you're really skilled but it's always
greater than zero there's always a
possibility you could lose that physical
fight
and unfortunately the same is true of
the legal fight
there's no way to reduce the risk of the
legal fight to zero you could do
everything
legally correct but then you're put in
front of a jury and if you're put in
front of a jury there's a 10
chance you're getting convicted because
that's just the noise in the system
because they might think a prosecutor
might convince them
shooting the knife out of someone's hand
is a reasonable thing to attempt right
and it's ridiculous it's ridiculous i
mean especially because depending what
kind of gun you have
it's just gonna it's gonna go behind the
knife it's gonna keep going
even if it hits the knife it's not
stopped by a knife held in someone's
hand the bullet is going to continue on
until
you know there's no such thing as a miss
with a bullet it continues going until
something stops it it hits
something yeah so so looking at like uh
the written house case and everything
we've seen from the escalation
of the lack of justice over the past you
know decade or so
or at least the attempts at stripping
justice away and the riots that have
resulted from it
i'm worried that rittenhouse is going to
get life they're going to give him
everything possible the jurors will
not stand up for him especially after
the photos of him i think with some
proud boys
they're going to be like deliberations
10 minutes can we go home now and order
pizza
lock them up and throw away the key
right so you might be able to tell
yourself well they're not supposed to
take into consideration that picture of
him with the proud boys i'm sure that
won't be admissible in court as actual
evidence
but of course the jury's not going to be
sequestered any more than this
were sequestered in the shelving case we
don't live in the 1970s where the news
is on at 6 and 10
as long as you don't turn on your tv
then you're not exposed to the news
we're immersed in the news constantly
those images of him with the proud boy
will be displayed prominently every day
of the trial the jury is un
unavoidably going to see it as long as
seeing maxine water as an equivalent
coming to town saying hey it better be
guilty
or this violence is going to escalate
and they'll be rioting the whole time
of course you really need a jury that
has no internet access
almost like right i know you need
impossible i know well it is
seems like it change of venues you have
to like put them in a place
so in the in the chauvin trial the
defense made motions for change of venue
almost every other day it seemed like
emotions for a continuance delaying the
trial to a later date almost every other
day
every time they did it the judge
rejected it and the judge's rationale
was essentially
listen this occurred in minnesota we
have to have the trial somewhere in
minnesota you can't have the trial
in some other jurisdiction is there
anywhere in minnesota
where the mob's not going to show up
where we're not going to have national
guardsmen we won't need barbed wire
or barriers the answer he thought was no
so even if we change it to another venue
another jurisdiction within the state
we're still going to have the same you
know vaccine waters
is not going to decline to go because
it's in a different city
in minnesota i i hear that and i think
the judge's
public statement was that but if i were
to make a guess and i know mind reading
we can't do that i'm imagining him you
know if
if i were going to make a guess about
what he actually thought is if i do this
they're going to come and burn my house
down
i'll just just let's lock this guy up
and get it over with right because the
only solution
if that's what you believe if you
believe hey we hold it here it's unfair
it's not a fair trial if we move it
elsewhere in minnesota
still not a fair trial to me the answer
to that dilemma is not
well we'll just give him an unfair trial
here right to me the answer to that
solution is if we're incapable
as a society of providing a fair trial
let him go you can't try the guy
i mean you just you dismissed the
charges with prejudice and you simply
can't subject
anybody to an unfair judicial process
could you imagine if blackstone's
formulation was still
upheld to this day they would have said
if the judge came out and said it's
impossible to have a fair trial
and then just out of my courtroom and
told all the writers it's your fault
right they would have burned the city
down and of course the judge knows this
which is
spineless basically they sacrificed this
guy and again listen he might be guilty
of criminal misconduct i don't know but
i do know for sure that this
process did not show that well so
because the process was corrupt
back to rittenhouse do you know when the
trial is supposed to be
i believe it's currently scheduled for
november but the nature of these things
is that things get rescheduled
a lot uh i'm sure of course rittenhouse
could push for a more accelerated trial
if he wants to we all have
a u.s constitutional right to a speedy
trial but generally the defendant
doesn't they want to delay as long as
possible to get as far
as possible in terms of time from the
event and the heat and the emotion
uh i mean there's a case in florida
where a retired cop shot somebody in a
movie theater
uh killed him uh over who knows what
throwing popcorn at each other or
something along those lines
i think that that's been seven years now
since that happened and that retired cop
still has not
gone to trial and he's 70 something
years old so i think the strategy is
you know if we delay long enough god
will take him before you know he'll be
subject to a prosecution
i'm worried that with written house
we're going to get another
uh i mean it's great for for the
leftists for the for the cult
they're going to claim another victory
in destroying the rule of law
proving that they that might makes right
they have the power
and that uh there's no justice in this
country anymore but i i'm scared about
what that's going what
what what that will mean to
conservatives and actually
anyone in this country who pays
attention i get it most of these
liberals who vote for the democrats
don't watch the news they don't they
don't they don't care they don't know
whatever cnn said it it's fine i guess
whatever
but there's a lot of people like me who
are slightly left leaning
and do follow the news and it's you know
the group of the politically homeless
the respected liberals
you combine those people with moderates
and conservatives and we are watching
the destruction of the justice system
and the fact that the judges the mayors
the prosecutor
all of these people are so pathetic
and spineless that they would rather
sell
out justice for their own skin instead
of standing up for what they believe in
and leading the charge on principle they
don't it's gone it could be like an
evolution of our justice system if we
if we fix it because i think in the
modern age those people are going to get
doxxed and they probably would have
their houses burned down and the judge
might have had his wife get remember
that one judge someone went to his house
and or one
house and murdered like she murdered her
husband and son i think her husband and
son
so i wonder if we can start to have
judicial processes where
it's um anonymous where you have
anonymous jurors
like porting into an avatar with um
absolutely encryption and an anonymous
judge
but you could somehow verify that they
are real people
american citizens i just don't see how
it could work you'd end up with some
kind of star
chamber proceeding that was like a
hidden justice
situation like from central america or
something and
and i think we have a right to to
first of all confront the accusers know
who our judges are to know who the
jurors are to be actively involved
and not have this information withheld
from you and it doesn't solve the
problem you still have the judge is
going to be known the expert witnesses
are going to be known all those people
are still going to be subject to
pressure
and unfortunately you know america is
exceptional in so many ways and one of
those ways is our
criminal due process protections that we
have like a right to confront your
attorney
uh your accuser a right to an attorney
this i've had that happen
but these protections exist for a reason
it's because they help ensure
something as close to justice as human
beings can create
and when you degrade that when you say
well maybe that guy didn't get a fair
trial but come on he had it coming
right i mean chauvin had it coming he
murdered george floyd or whoever you
think
might have it coming when you degrade
that person's criminal
process protections you do it for
everybody right because none of us can
expect
any more criminal due process than that
guy got not you
not your kids not your wife not your
brother not your parents
nobody can expect any more than we give
the worst of us which is why we've
always given the worst of us
those protections there are pro bono
attorneys
who go down to guantanamo bay to
represent
terrorists we put nazis on trial
after world war ii and now we have a
large faction of people in this country
who want to destroy that
and did you hear what many of these
people were saying in the chauvin trial
they
you you had prominent outlets saying the
nation said
in a re something to the effect of in a
reasonable world there wouldn't have
even been a trial
he should have just taken the plea and
it'd be over you you have prominent
activists on twitter saying why are we
even holding a trial we all watched it
on video
they don't care for the rule of law no
and that's unfortunate because
that's not really a world that i think
any of us would want to live in
unfortunately i think the judge and the
jurors are not getting due process
either because
with this the crowd mob mentality and
the ability for people to organize on
twitter and docs and like go to their
house that day and be like hey i'm not
in you know louisiana but you are go get
this address in louisiana
they're not safe sure but if you're like
a spineless coward like judge cahill
then you shouldn't be adjusting well if
in reality if your choices he's gonna
die or i'm gonna die
and that's just your job what are you
gonna choose
well if you're a coward you'll you'll
you'll let the innocent person suffer to
save your own skin
but if you're brave and principled you
will say i will stand my ground so be it
then that's
a lot to expect from a civil servant
that's right oh absolutely
it may be the standard we should expect
right arguably but they'll just get
replaced
but it's it's a lot to expect it's a guy
it's insane to expect that no that's not
a way to survive a society no no no you
can't expect the judges to sacrifice
themselves
if every single judge every time said
f you you will not terrorize me into
putting an innocent man in prison we
would not have this problem i don't
think so i think that
they then they would get destroyed by
who by what by the angry mob
and then the government would put new
obedient judges into place issue of
complacent
spineless and feckless leadership the
prosecutors who won't prosecute the
rioters
the police who grovel and lick the boots
of their democratic leadership that
sells them out
and you have you have a system where as
you mentioned prosecutors are like i'm
going to pass the buck i don't want to
be involved
grow a spine and go on tv and say this
is what happened if you've got a problem
with it i don't know to tell you
why we have covert ops you don't want to
know who or you're not supposed to know
who the people spying on you are because
you'll go they'll go get executed so
you kind of i don't i don't necessarily
think we need like secret
judges and juries making these like
behind-the-scenes decisions but if there
was a way to protect their identities
uh that i think is the future of of
judiciary unite
america the public has a right to know i
do agree with that but
only to know that they're real people
you don't need to know their identity
their identities i disagree what if what
if what if the government starts putting
up juries of a bunch of uh tech
billionaires and you're like well
they're real people we know it's true
we don't know who they are and it's all
a bunch of billionaires or gang members
or whatever you could maybe know
you don't give the government the power
to do that government needs to be
transparent the problem is
all of these politicians in minnesota
are sitting there thinking like
well i'm more important than anyone else
i don't care about my community
or the betterment of my children's
future i would rather sell
everyone else out to save my own skin
that's what they're saying well i think
they think it's a transient problem i
think they're thinking hey
we got this droid floyd trial going on
now the shove and trial
let's just get through it we'll get
through it it'll be over if we can get
through it without the city incurring a
billion dollars in property damage and a
bunch of other people getting killed
well that means we've got to sacrifice
one cop maybe not give them perfect
due process of law well that's just
that's just the price we're gonna pay
we're not gonna
we're not gonna incur those billions of
dollars of property and that's even
before you get to their own
self-interest my job my career my safety
so they can frame it in their minds as
doing the greatest good for the greatest
number of people
and let's face it it's not like chauvin
fell off a building onto george floyd he
was actively using
force on george floyd and they made to
tell themselves listen he took the job
as a cop this is one of the risks
especially in this political environment
he could have retired the year before
right and not been doing that he has
that right no one was making him be a
cop
and that's why i say any one of these
cops in minnesota right now
the next time this happens kim potter i
don't i don't care
they can lock kim kim potter what was it
second degree manchester was that 10
years
i'd have to check it's something in that
range 10 to 20 years and then she'll
probably get
four or something because she's not no
criminal history you know but there's a
lot there's other aggravating factors so
once they decide it's a crime they
convict you on anything well then you're
a criminal
and then you committed the crime while
in police uniform wearing a badge and
that becomes an aggravating factor for
sentencing i mean that's what chauvin's
looking at now so
under under normal sentencing guidelines
with no priors he'd be looking at about
10 years
which means he'd get out in like six
years but they filed what they call
for blakely aggravating factors uh he
was a cop
wearing a badge in uniform in front of
children
uh part of a group of people the other
police officers involved so he could be
looking at
way more time than time you do you think
these officers
in minnesota would hesitate to arrest
you on a gun charge if you were
if you were constitutionally bearing
constitutionally expressing your right
to bear arms
not if it violated a minnesota statute
they'd arrest you in a heartbeat
on the spot yeah and so you have you
have these cops
that we you see the violence and the
destruction happening in these places
they also don't want law-abiding
citizens to have the ability to defend
themselves
now i understand the cops aren't the
ones who made the laws but being the
ones who enforce it at a time when the
city
has been attacked when buildings have
been destroyed the police department is
under threat
and they still work to support a system
they know is crooked
after everything that happened they
would still without hesitation take away
your right to defend yourself as a law
abiding citizen
and then after choosing to stand in a
burning building
while threatening my rights to
self-defense expect me to defend them
never going to happen kim potter can go
to prison for all i care she chose this
she knows what the corrupt spineless
politicians are doing and i
have no sympathy for anybody who chooses
to stand in a burning building when i
say get out and they don't
well a lot of them are getting out some
of them some of them
you know they may make different choices
but the fact is every cop knows that he
doesn't work for himself
he's not his own law enforcement agency
he works for a hierarchy of people above
him and ultimately he works for
politicians so
his police chief the guy at the top of
his department that is a political
position folks that's not a law
enforcement position just because he
wears a uniform and has a badge
he's not a cop anymore he's a politician
now
so ultimately the cops don't work for
themselves they work
for the politicians if they don't like
doing that then they can't keep the job
they shouldn't i mean after after
everything that's happened my attitude
is
for one if you're still going to stay in
these cities
where all these problems are happening
it's not just
happening in a vacuum it's not like all
of a sudden i'm standing alongside these
leftists being like yeah all cops are
bad no no i'm not saying that at all
what i'm saying is
we had we had a what what are we going
on now almost a year of riots
now before the before the election we
had
months of rioting we had a political
system supporting the rioters we had a
kamala harris soliciting funds for the
rioters joe biden's staff
donating funds for the rioters absolute
support
for the cast and the destruction and an
establishment media saying peaceful
protests while their fire raging behind
them
and i said okay let's defend you know uh
our police officers not all perfect
should be police accountability i
respect all that
the trial i get let's have a fair trial
let's have some police reform
the argument didn't work the people
decided that they should vote for those
who supported the rioters
we are seeing an escalation of or should
say a collapse of our justice system
and there are still to this day cops
saying i'm going to sit here in a
burning building okay
well when the fire started and we all
tried putting it out and it didn't work
and the fire took over the building
then i said time to get out of the
building guys you said no i'm cool i'll
stay i say all right
so when the building comes down on you
don't expect me to get sick it's a real
dilemma right because
what what choices do the cops have they
can stay or they can go
if they go they're not cops anymore so
they're not helping us there right
they're not
they're not good why not what how is it
not helping
if they're gonna stay in a city that is
if they're supporting corrupt
politicians
and corrupt judges saying if they leave
the job they're not fighting crime
anymore
right they're not serving that societal
purpose anymore because they're no
longer police they've they've left the
job
if they stay maybe they feel they can
still most of the time
do something for crime but yes
admittedly by staying you're working for
the body politic that gives you that job
and you've got uh uh resident residents
of these cities
who don't want to do anything to support
the police to express their support for
police well apparently quite the
opposite
why why are people marching they're
voting for the prosecutors and they're
voting for the lawyers they're voting
for the
you know their support supporting the
anti-police initiative
so then what gives these cops the right
to reject the will of the people and
think they can stay here and go into
these neighborhoods where they don't
or they aren't wanted well they can
because the politicians say
you can go and just be be don't be
surprised when
we serve you up in the next witch trial
so these cops
and the good ones won't stay i mean any
that can get out with any
any fraction of whatever they've earned
in terms of a pension
uh they're going to leave uh they leave
the profession entirely or they'll join
the state police or the sheriff's
department or
move to some other jurisdiction entirely
they'll get out while they can you know
when you look at the the all the
they had a lot of police testify for the
state during the chauvin trial
uh none of them were street cops they
were from the academy
they were trainers uh or they were a hum
an 80 year old or 70 year old homicide
detective who doesn't do street work
anymore he shows up after everything's
done and talks to witnesses
or they had a sergeant who again shows
up after the fact
if there's been certain use of force
threshold reached you have to call your
sergeant so he can write a report
but none of them are making hands-on
arrests they didn't call any street cops
you know who called a street cop
the defense called a street cop the guy
who was involved in the first
george floyd intentional ingestion of
drugs
related arrests he and he was there to
attest to the body cam video
and he was like yeah no this is what
george floyd does
this is should have been entirely
expected because this is
the same behavior that i experienced and
he stepped right through it and there's
a reason
the prosecution didn't call any actual
street cops because they didn't want
street cop testimony
in that trial what they got were the
cops who were still there
who weren't on the street because
they're in the academy they're in
headquarters during senior homicide
positions
where they're not actually expected to
go hands-on with anybody
i look at what's going on in many of
these cities and just think
the cops at this point who are staying
are propping up a corrupt system
and they're allowing it to persist and
it's more than that
i for a while operate under the
assumption that regular people wanted
police
and i noticed a lot of conservatives do
this where it's like clearly people want
crime to be stopped
but then i saw the mikaya bryant thing
when
when and i saw that instant in new york
city where the woman got shot in the
head
and i realized something they're telling
us
in no uncertain terms and we're just not
getting it through our thick skulls
when a woman shoots another one in the
head in new york it's not news no one
cares trump doesn't show up there's no
lawsuits no lawyers no one complains
cops don't got to do anything cops
aren't at risk cops are fine the people
want to live that way
when mikaya bryant is fighting and she
pulls a knife and tries to stab someone
the cop intervenes
immediately in that body camera footage
i was amazed to see
the people turned the cops yelling what
did you do why did you do that it's like
didn't you just watch this lady wind up
with the knife
and then i thought to myself it's clear
they're not lying they're literally
saying
let us have neighborhoods riddled with
violence and crime we want that
we don't want your you to intervene in
fact
there was there was one instant uh
instance recently where i think someone
someone had their kid killed
i can't know what the story was the guy
is refusing to talk to the cops about it
at all
and he said we do not want cops coming
in our neighborhood period
and i'm like then why are cops still
doing it why is anyone demanding
they should no the cops should leave
because the people have asked them to
right that's simple and of course every
cop knows now that if he does go hand on
with a suspect the first thing that's
going to happen is all the bystanders
are going to come to the immediate
conclusion that his use of force was
inappropriate unlawful and those are
exactly the kinds of witnesses that were
brought up in the chauvin trial
by the way they mostly testified about
their feelings
about what happened which should not be
relevant in the criminal prosecution
that frankly they should not have been
permitted to say those words when they
said those words
it should have been objected to by the
defense i wondered why the defense
didn't object at the time
sometimes there's a broader strategy
that pays off later where you don't want
to be objecting even when you have the
privilege
unfortunately i never saw the payback
appear later during the trial so i'm not
sure what the defense counsel was there
for
they're supposed to testify about facts
their observations of what happened not
their feelings about what happened
we had witness after witness after
witness literally
gasp and cry and tear on the witness
stand
that alone should be grounds for a
reversal of this conviction
so i wanted to talk i thought i had this
pulled up um
it's probably here somewhere where is it
i don't know
we have the the supreme court's gonna be
taking up uh
a case on gun rights and so throughout
all of this if one thing can be said
it's that
we have record gun sales you know we're
seeing more first-time gun buyers than
than you know
record-breaking first-time gun buyer uh
gun buyers
people want to defend themselves and now
there's huge news where gun rights
advocates are really excited the supreme
court is going to
rule on whether or not the right to keep
and bear arms exists outside of your
home
but i do think it's funny that a lot of
people think it's going to be a positive
and the left seems like it's gonna be a
negative probably because the court is
i guess on paper six to three even
though it's probably more likely five to
four
there's a good possibility that they
rule against gun rights and based on the
track record we've seen over the past
couple of years it seems more likely to
me that the supreme court is going to
rule we don't have the right to keep and
bear arms
i i don't understand the people in the
gun community who are just assuming that
this is going to be a positive outcome
on this case
it's i mean were they happy with how the
supreme court dealt with the election
issues
after the presidential election because
they basically just washed their hands
of the whole affair
maybe that was appropriate maybe not i'm
not an expert in election law
not even really an expert in gun law my
expertise is use of force law
but you know politics is downstream of
culture and to think that you could lose
the culture
lose the legislature lose the executive
branch and somehow the supreme court's
going to step in with a cape and save
you at the end
strikes me as an unrealistic expectation
for any kind of sustained society
i'm looking at everything that's going
on you know with uh we've been talking a
lot about
the chauvin trial and frankly the
injustice i mean
people the juror flat out saying she was
scared of riots and destruction i think
that's all you need to hear but
obviously you can see with your own eyes
how it was influencing the jury now we
have the very real prospect
that come well you know it could be good
it could be bad
but i'm i'm i'm sorry if i'm being
pessimistic but come october it's
october 4th i think is when they're
gonna
uh hear that hear the case they could
come out and take away our rights
and i think that's that's the trend so
far things have been just seemingly
seemingly uh seemingly getting worse in
terms of our rights in these areas
well i think the worst case scenario is
not that the supreme court says
you can't conceal carry anymore if
you're allowed to do it currently in
your state
they're not going to take away a right
but what they would do is leave on the
table the option that hey if a state
does if a state wants to take away that
right they're privileged to do that
new jersey doesn't want to give you a
concealed carry permit new york doesn't
maryland doesn't i'm not sure how things
work here but if the state decides that
you basically don't have a right to
carry a firearm outside of your home
the state's free to do that it wouldn't
affect you if you live in a state where
you're currently allowed to carry unless
of course the politics in your state
changes like in my home state of
colorado they just passed a new gun
control laws
in the last week or so the state is
becoming more like california
less than the colorado i moved into i
don't expect gun laws to get
better there over time and if they know
they have the permission of the supreme
court to crank
down and diminish the right to keep and
bear arms
i expect that they'll take advantage of
that so i'm curious though
by what logic could they could the
supreme court say the right to keep and
bear arms doesn't exist outside of your
home
well there's no logical basis but if you
read any of these second amendment
decisions that favor gun control
especially like decisions out of the
ninth circuit for example in california
read the decision it's not a legally
reasoned
decision it's what i call word salad
they're just making noises
it's like listening to someone argue
with their spouse and one of them is
being
completely unreasonable just to kind of
score points on the other
they're just saying what they think they
need to say in order to justify
affirming
an infringement of the second amendment
but it's not based on reason these are
emotional not rational decisions so like
talking about mass shootings and things
like that
it's arguments like well why would you
ever need more than like six rounds and
a gun right which is the
what new york state had for some time
maybe still it was a six round what
maximum limit
but wasn't it you could have like a 10
round magazine but you only put six more
only six
bullets in it i mean and by the way it's
also important to keep in mind that of
course
none of these laws none of them actually
affect
bad actors bad actors don't obey
gun laws they don't do background checks
they buy their cars out of the trunks
guns out of the trunks of cars they or
they send their girlfriends or mothers
into the gun store to buy the gun as a
straw purchase
they don't have any respect for magazine
limits they don't care about
not being allowed to carry in a school
zone they are
criminals which means they don't obey
the law so all these
if one of the criteria for infringing
appropriately on a constitutional right
is supposed to be at least it will
accomplish the desired effect
well then gun control laws by their very
nature can't do that because they don't
affect the criminal actor
so we've got an erosion of the criminal
justice system and an erosion of the
right to self-defense
is the goal just to destroy the country
is that hyperbolic i don't think the
people making those arguments would
claim that's the goal but i believe from
their perception the goal
is the accumulation of political capital
for some and frankly just straight-up
financial capital for others
and they are gaining political capital i
mean they get elected to these offices
they get
put in charge they are making the
decisions
and if people don't like those decisions
they would need to elect other
politicians but they don't they don't
because most people aren't paying
attention most people don't care that's
the interesting thing about the whole
vote argument are you familiar with
starship troopers
very much so uh service guarantees
citizenship is that what it was
so uh we have a country right now where
the right to vote
is what's the what's the right word um
voting is becoming increasingly more and
more universal to the point where the
democrats have argued that 16 year olds
should have a right to vote
my argument has been like well i'm not
saying it should it should be
you know uh impossible to vote or we
should go back to the way it was where
you'd be a landowner or anything
but i certainly think at the very least
you have to choose to vote if you want
to vote right so we see the unsolicited
mail-in belts being sent to people
they're not even choosing to vote and
they're getting sent the ballots so
they're going to i don't know whatever
sure right so politics and public policy
are not my area of expertise but i would
note that it's
to my mind it's an open question whether
universal democracy
is a system that can work there's a
legitimate concern that once
the majority of 51 percent realizes they
can simply
vote themselves the resources of the 49
that you don't have a functioning
society anymore because the 49
will not be subjugated like that they
will not accept that
the us was set up to have a bill of
rights
partly to constrain the government and
its ability to infringe on our
natural rights but also to provide
protections for the minority
so just having 51 did not entitle you to
do
anything you wanted there were
constraints on the government for just
that purpose
it's interesting because i often you
hear the argument from many democrats
more of the corporate uh type that
you know the these a fringe minority has
50
senate seats or whatever you know it's
like you look at these states like
wyoming and they've got two senators and
it's like right because you're not
supposed to have the right to oppress
the minority
it's supposed to be that compromise is
required and
one state doesn't get to tell another
state what to do just because there's
more people living there it's not a
direct democracy well
also the senators were not originally
voted by popular vote
the senators were not supposed to be
representing the people
the senators were representing the
states the states as
independent political entities the house
of representatives
represented the people house of
representatives
the senators were the political actors
for the state
themselves as separate political
entities in conflict with the federal
government
well now everything is just slowly
broken apart i think it was uh
ben sasse is that his name he said uh we
should repeal i think it was the 17th
that's the one that made the senate
uh senators elected by the people as
opposed to appointed by the state i
think you're correct
yeah so it was interesting when i saw
that because it's an interesting
argument
if you were at the local level voting
for your local politicians
if you elected the right people they
would appoint the right senator you'd be
happy with it
but what's happened now is no one even
knows who their local politicians are
they have no idea who represents their
county or i mean even their state well
one of the
dynamics i think we increasingly see is
that
if you wanted to buy elections you
wanted to buy politicians
just with money not no popular support
for those people
you wouldn't target a thousand small
elections you target a handful of big
elections
governors presidents and i think we're
seeing a lot of states where the
legislature
may be republican maybe by a large
majority and somehow they have a
democratic governor right
how does that happen well it happens
because money comes in to support that
democrat politician to win that single
race you focus
all your energies on that race you let
the other team
win all the smaller elections because as
long as you hold that executive branch
office
you can veto whatever the legislature
does unless you're able to override your
veto but it's a disproportionate amount
of power
that if you expended that money in a
bunch of little races and came up with
only 49
then you effectively have no power this
is why i'm a big fan
of or at least i i like to enter
entertain the idea that we don't allow
people to donate
outside of their outside of their their
districts where they live where they
declare residency
because you look at someone like
ocasio-cortez and she gets millions
you know plus from outside of her
district pretty sure the same is true
for margaery taylor green
not a fan of any of it the people who
live in the area should be the ones
making decisions instead
people are dumping money not only into
the donations of the candidate
themselves
but into commercials in those districts
to swing these elections
and then you get people in hollywood
going into
republican areas and getting democrats
to win these races right so how do you
stop
that right i mean i i understand the
motivation behind a lot of this
election funding regulation uh laws that
are passed i just don't ever see it
being effective because there's always
ways to work around it
and then there's non-monetary ways to
support a politician that you can't do
anything about if movie stars are going
to come in
and campaign for one person running for
an election
that's going to have an influence if
only because they'll get tv
time it's effectively free tv commercial
space exactly
for that politician and i don't see any
way to stop that from happening you're
right right and and for me on this show
you know ian brought this up the last
time we talked about it
well by by the nature of having a show
with viewers
it would give me more power over anyone
else because i can do a show from
wherever i want and speak who i think is
the right person to win
and it's power it's powerful it's
influence so it's it's difficult
what ends up happening is we have a
system where
the people of of new york's uh 14th
did not legitimately in my opinion or i
should say
didn't uh what's the right word i want
to say
knowledgeably right like like they
didn't understand what they were voting
for
fairly and i don't mean to single out
aoc's district it's basically every
district
save a few smaller ones in certain areas
no one really cares to fight over
but many of these people are just given
propaganda
it's it's it's republicans and democrats
every single uh there's there's
very little honesty in politics period
right so
what percentage of the populists who can
vote votes anyway
like in a presidential election is it
even half something like that
i think it was uh it was more than half
this time right and how many do it in a
pro forma basis where they're just hey
it's my obligation i'll just show up and
and vote they're not really informed
about the issues
and that's in the higher level races so
when you get to the lower races like we
talked about earlier with who your local
prosecutor is they have no
idea who those names are none and so
somebody can drop in a few tv
commercials in that district they just
became
the prosecutor in that district i wish
it was possible to say
hey your vote doesn't count unless it's
a well-informed
decision but we don't have a mechanism
for doing that
service guarantees citizenship i'm only
i'm only uh
i'm actually i wouldn't say half kidding
75 percent kidding i like the idea of
having some kind of civic requirement
for being involved in
in civics in some capacity but i say
75 kidding because i wouldn't even know
you'd implement that right how would
this restrict certain people who
shouldn't be how would it you know
not restrict those who should be none of
us would go out to our local supermarket
and canvas
the first 20 people we meet to ask them
how they should run their own household
right right what should i wear today
you're not going to ask other people
what should i invest my money in because
you'll get lunatic responses but all
those people
get to elect your government for you
right does that make sense
i don't know in our system of government
that's the public policy decision well i
mean
human beings have had different systems
throughout history uh i'm not sure
universal democrat majority rules
everything
uh polity is one that's long-term
sustainable
no it's not right now the cult worship
thing where like you put one person in
power and then that one person becomes
like
the cult leader like ron rand paul he's
a target
for bribes and they just get massive uh
paul's a target for brazil all of them i
just picked him randomly brand's like
one of the only ones i like yeah he's
pick somebody else
he's still bribable like like a
corporation comes in with 60 million or
take him out to dinner or lunch and they
want to fund his pack
or his campaign and not not ran not you
any any of these people
so that's like a a weak point in our
system is that we have these individuals
that can be bribed and and bought
and commercial it's not so simple though
when when marco rubio was doing a town
hall they questioned him they said
i think it was rubio it might have been
ted cruz they were like you're getting
money from the nra and he's like yeah
they just give me money because they
like what i already do they're not
bribing me
but the perspective was no you've been
bribed by them it's like no i'm pro-gun
so they gave me money because they want
me to win
but this is as this is just another way
of saying they're all human beings i
mean if you look at
the roman empire during caesar he had
the same drivers he needed money he went
to war because that's how you acquired
money
he had to pay off debts debts he
accumulated by running for elections and
getting political favors
this is just a normal this is what
people do this is how you work with
other people to build political capital
it's not because everyone's uh perfect
and pure in the in the in their hearts
but you know you know i think the
problem is we are seeing an increasing
detachment from community
where you have judges or prosecutors or
individuals who just say i don't care
about my neighbor and i don't care about
my country
i think the bigger problem is we're
becoming more emotionally
driven and i think that's largely
because of the way social media works
today
i think the the news media has always
been a powerful influencer of how people
see the world i mean
william hearst bought newspapers so he
could influence the world
because he could people only know what
they see they know what they read if
they don't see it and read it
it doesn't exist it's invisible to them
so what they see written and how they
see it portrayed
becomes their lived reality in the era
but that was when you might get a
morning paper or an evening paper or see
the news at six o'clock or ten o'clock
for 30 minutes at a time
now we're all immersed in this stream of
propaganda and a motive clicking and
baiting
all day long i mean personally i've
taken the social media apps
off my smartphone just to not be
constantly interrupted and subject to
that
if this if these social media platforms
were drugs
is there any doubt they would be
controlled substances is it any doubt
you'd have to be
21 or 38 or 42 before you could legally
access that kind of content they're
drugs and there would only be a few that
would be legal like alcohol
it would be youtube right or facebook or
twitter all the other ones would be
controlled
i think we're on the verge of uh i think
i think the internet as we know it is
has been ending for some time i think
you know was the wild west several you
know 10 20 years ago
now it's becoming more and more
corporatized we're seeing you know
youtube
lock everything down they're picking the
winners and the losers they're getting
rid of a lot of they don't like
twitter is doing the same thing they're
trying to homogenize and create a mono
culture
now i will add one last thing um what's
going on in florida with this uh this
this
that passed the senate about censorship
is going to be the it's
it's like a nuclear bomb being dropped
in social media in the internet
because the way i understand it this
would end wikipedia as we know it could
be just gone wikipedia can't exist
because they wouldn't be able to remove
news sources they deem unreliable
because that would violate the law which
says
you can't remove a journalistic
enterprise for their content or opinions
but the politicians who voted for that
can they realistically
stay politicians if they're demonized by
social media if they're outcast if
they're removed from those platforms
when even the sitting president of the
united states
has trouble with social media platforms
if you're a local politician in florida
and you can't facebook or tweet or use
social media to communicate with your
constituents but your opponent in the
race
can do you really stand a chance that's
why they passed the law
or that's why it's it's all it's going
through it went to the senate that's why
rhonda sanders wants to sign it because
it has to be done now before it's too
late and it may already
already be too late and if if they'd
done this back in 2018
when i recall when i called the
republicans too stupid to deal with the
problem to save their own careers and
then sure enough they ended up losing
what like 30 something seats
so there it is hopefully that you know
what they do there will have an impact
but uh that being said
let's go to super chats my friends if
you have not already you must
smash that like button because it really
does help and leave your comments we're
gonna read through your
super chats and don't forget to go to
timcast.com become a member because
we'll have a member's only exclusive
segment coming up around 11 we do we put
it up every night and uh share the show
if you like it
if you're listening to itunes or spotify
give us a good review let's read
some super chats all right well
i got bad news for the first super chat
youtube has a bar blocking your name i
can't read it i don't know why they do
that
but you said hi mates from the uk here
can i get a shout out for
voice of wales a small channel as both
the labor party and the bbc both lobbied
youtube and twitter to get them
cancelled for not being woke enough
cheers right on jordan jones says i hope
the 2a case makes its way through the
court before may 15th
so i know whether or not to send my tax
payment to the irs or just give it to
tx well texas they're not going to hear
that case to october right
i honestly don't know what the schedule
is right and then whenever they hear it
it's you know weeks or months before we
actually get a decision out of them
wow check this out gerald armstrong says
we are in a curfew here in elizabeth
city from now until 6 a.m tomorrow
wow where's that that's north carolina
where they've got the state of emergency
because of uh
potential for black lives matter riots
they're they're really worried
by the way that's another way that the
jury was influenced in the chauvin trial
even if they obeyed the judge's
restrictions to not
watch the news about the case they were
getting alarms on their phones right
every time curfew was initiated
so you know that's not good news for
your community right you know there's a
potential for riots and that
influences you despite your best efforts
to avoid the news
stephen pritchard says tim come rafting
with me in harper's ferry
look up river and trail outfitters i
don't know if you saw steven but we were
drinking harper's ferry brewery
a couple weeks ago we have a bunch of
those beers because we just you know we
pop by and we're like
we'll grab a bunch of beers while we're
over there and it's particularly close
so i think we're right by
whatever uh that that location
fractal says joe biden needs some bio
trust maybe he'll grow a spine
incorporating the sponsor into your burn
of the president very nice
wd-40 says all right let's see uh
wd-40 says hey tim why should i
right-wing gun guy advocate for
black people in democrat cities to have
the right to bear arms
when they vote 90 90 against gun rights
they voted for it
let them live with it it's a good point
but second amendment isn't in
expresses the government's inability to
infringe upon an inalienable right
so when i say like the people in these
cities vote to abolish their police
departments
well that's a choice the community makes
as to how they want to live and the cops
shouldn't stand for in dignity
and they should know when they're not
wanted everybody has a right to keep
them bear arms
you have a right to to a weapon that's
just it's true
the founding fathers didn't say the
government must you know
not like the constitution doesn't grant
the right
the founding fathers were literally
saying no one can take that right from
you because it was bestowed upon you by
your creator
so we're telling the government to back
off everybody has that right
age old man you had to pick up a club
and defend yourself in caveman times
and weapons are there for a reason or at
least we've we've turned
tools into weapons for a reason black
lion grunt says omg a suit
tim get this man a beanie you're wearing
a suit how many people have we had on
whoa
you're wearing jeans well it's like a
mullet for lawyers
business on the top party on the bottom
the zoom outfit
km says you guys should get billy corgan
on get on a twitch
is billy on twitch um billy corgan huge
fan and uh i would love to have billy
corgan on the show sometime
yeah anytime but we have to talk about
dmt when he's on i'm sure he'd be super
into that
and that would be that would be epic
mediocre fisherman says hey tim when are
you going to write a book if you didn't
know
michael knowles book speechless is on
pre-ordering uh he got me
i love it he got me promoting michael
knowles's book
crossover is complete senior hones says
tim please talk to someone who has
knowledge and experience in law
enforcement find someone or give me 30
minutes and so i can explain away a lot
of your misconceptions
we are trying to get people from law
enforcement um
we're doing we'll we'll see we can we
can uh pull off but we're we're
actively trying all right we got a bunch
of super chat so let's let's see what uh
we got
butters oregano says what is mr bronco's
opinion on uscca insurance for those of
us that carry
so he's asking about what some people
call self-defense insurance policies
they're not really insurance but
effectively they promise to cover your
legal expenses if you're involved in the
use of force event
uh there's only uh in full disclosure i
partner with one of these companies it's
not uscca it's a company called ccw
safe so take that into consideration my
main concern with uscca is frankly that
they have a limit on their coverage that
i think is too low so
it's a lot of money it's a quarter of a
million dollars that's a lot of money by
anybody's estimation
and if you're in an aggravated assault
case you pointed a gun at someone but
didn't shoot
facing felony aggravated assault that's
almost certainly enough money for your
defense
but if you've shot someone in
self-defense and you're getting
prosecuted
you'll go through two hundred thousand
dollars easily pre-trial wow and if
there's only 50 000 left for the trial
it's not enough it's just not enough
money so it's not
200 grand if a lot of people are armed
and defend themselves i can't imagine
someone having the ability
having the ability to actually defend
themselves right so that's why i prefer
ccw safe because they don't place that
cap
they just pay whatever the legal cost is
period uh
it's not because uscca is bad people if
there's anything wrong with them i think
they're perfectly fine but i think if
you're involved in a killing charge case
murder or manslaughter
250 is not enough to cover your legal
expenses it's just not or
you get that much legal defense when you
really need two or three or four times
that much
wow i mean the george zimmerman case for
example i i've become very good friends
with the attorneys involved in that case
since that happened
1.7 million dollars for that legal
defense now they didn't get paid that
they kept working for free
uh but that's the kind of money we're
talking about in these cases
wow eric babb says andrew branca i've
been wanting you guys to bring him on
for so long
wrote the literal book on the law of
self-defense people can learn so much
from this man that's right you have a
book
i have a book in fact for all of you
watching we have a
free book offer this is the book if you
go to law self defense dot com slash
tim poole really yup the book's normally
25
we make it available free we do ask you
to pay what we have to pay the post
office to get it to you
so the shipping and handling but we eat
the 25 cost of the book
so law self-defense dot com slash
timpool and you can get this
wonderful book that by the way we have
almost a thousand reviews of this on
amazon it's solid five-star rating so if
you want a kind of quality check in that
way but don't order it from them they'll
charge you the full price
can you sign that one and give it to us
absolutely of course cool
cork gaming says tim i live in martin
county kentucky
our sheriff a few years back when we
were having a shortage of officers
so maybe as a typo in here we're having
a shortage of officers we were told to
get a guard dog and a gun it made news
wow wow crazy
ossery says i'm going to disagree with
him on the aubrey case i'm a former
g-a-l-e-o and they met none of the
requirements to enact
a citizen's arrest mainly the mcdaniels
did not witness a felony
well he doesn't understand georgia's
citizens arrest law
you have to have a reasonable belief
that a felony has been committed they
saw arbori
go into property they knew was not his
this was a neighbor's house
there had been thefts there before so
the local police had asked them to keep
an eye on the property
under georgia law if you enter a
property with an intent
to steal that's felony burglary once
there's reasonable belief a felony may
have been committed
you have the privilege under georgia
citizens arrest law to make
a citizen's arrest they don't need to be
right
that a felony was committed they have to
have a reasonable belief
that a felony was committed and if
they're privileged to arrest
they're definitely privileged to stop
because a stop is a lesser degree
of constraint to someone's freedom than
an arrest would be interesting
coldwater says i think it's great to
have legal experts like andrew branca to
educate us on the law fair taking place
what conservative legal organization
should an average conservative join
something not the aclu i guess
if you're a gun owner i would suggest a
second amendment foundation i'm a life
member there
unlike the nra the second amendment
foundation actually goes to court
to fight these gun law cases and they
win
a very high percentage of the time very
cool
sam t says chauvin had 18 formal
complaints and wasn't really held
accountable
he is clearly incompetent unions
protected him
well you wouldn't know of 18 was a
meaningful number
over a 19-year career unless you knew
what was typical for the department
every officer gets complaints filed
against him these are people who for a
living
go hands-on with people make arrests of
people
people very rarely like getting arrested
or being manhandled by the police
complaints are common whether 18 is a
significant number is impossible to know
unless you knew what was typical
in that department by the way there's a
reason none of that
was admissible in evidence in court
against chauvin in this case because
it's not relevant
to whether he did anything wrong in this
event i don't know if i can
uh if i should ask one of these someone
has a question for you but it pertains
to written house i don't know if uh
i'll go ahead ask it i'll tell you all
right i'm not
by the way the reason tim is uh hesitant
here is because i indicated i'm not
currently involved in the written house
case but there's a possibility i might
be so
well this question is perfectly
reasonable so credit disciple says
andrew since you were so confident that
as 100 self-defense why are you not on
his defense team
keeping this kid out of prison or
protecting himself you can afford a pro
bono case here
why i don't work pro bono sorry
i have four kids to support in a costly
german motorcycle habit so i i need to
get paid for the work that i do
uh but they i may be involved in the
case it's up to them if they'd like me
to work on the case and and whether
it would be you know mutually beneficial
brandon the jobber says if kyle is
convicted do you think we uh
you think we'll see retaliation from the
right most people on the right say free
kyle
i just don't see political violence from
the right in any meaningful dimension so
it's not a thing that happens i'm sorry
folks the craziest thing
is that from the right the worst thing
we've seen in a long time
and i mean from the actual political
body in this country not like fringe
lunatics who are obviously insane
but like trump supporters and
conservatives was the capital
where i think it was actually the only
person who
was killed in violence was actually by
the capitol police
and then some people died incidentally
from i think like a stroke or getting
trampled
right so did they burn it down because
that's what they do the left does in
these cities
right they loot it um destruction of
property
i mean it was so incidental in such a
brief period of time
and then it was over when it came to
like by the way anybody responsible for
doing any of those things should be held
legally accountable absolutely
so if you damage property if you loot it
if you hurt someone
you should absolutely be held legally
accountable but i see those activities
happening on the left
at levels that are orders of magnitude
greater
than i ever see from the right yeah my
response to the shoving case wasn't to
destroy stuff even though i thought it
was gross injustice from my perspective
but was to change the system itself i
don't know if
maybe extremists don't go that route but
that's if if something happens to
written house which also seems like a
self-defense case i would just
opt harder to change the system whatever
that means
or actually just get real justice all
right jason
jason spruill says i live in i live in
the elizabeth city area
and the protests seem peaceful so far
but they appear to be building to
something more
people are currently blocking roads and
violating curfew right so what's
happening now likely in the
in the elizabeth city case is that the
people in these other cities
these activists they have to get there
so it usually takes a good week while
all of the activists and organizers come
from various cities
and then coalesce into the one city
where the latest
instance is happening let me just
explain something for everybody don't
understand this
you think these activists show up for
black lives matter that doesn't explain
why they show up in china
or turkey which they do i know some
activists who lived in turkey for quite
some time they showed there
because they are international
socialists they're anti-fun they fly the
flag in various countries
so activists in the us will be like ooh
protests are happening in turkey i'll go
there all protests are happening in
ukraine i'll go there or venezuela
to go and support support this
international leftist cause
so when they descend on elizabeth city
it's not because they actually care
about the cops it's because anything to
destroy the system
that's their goal not all of them just
we call them the tourists
all right let's see flying raptor jesus
says if i was kyle
i'd flee and blame a biased jury based
on the chauvin trial
everyone knows it will be unfair maybe
we need the amish to be jurors they're
the only ones that don't have internet
and definitely are impartial
i'm not sure they don't have internet
though i think it's kind of changed
no i think there's like misconceptions
about what amish people actually do
and you know i i've seen them on tv
commercials right
and there's um i i went to there was
like this big amish marketplace
sounds awesome they're all doing normal
things i don't know you know people
assume amish people are like
completely baffled by technology and
it's like i think they just for the most
part don't use it but they have it
there was a farmer's mark in chicago
where like a truck pulled up and it was
like amish
you know farming or whatever and they
had like a bunch of vegetables and i was
like
i was like so you guys are ambitious
like yeah and i'm like i thought you
like yeah i know everybody thinks we
don't but like
they can still do this stuff for certain
reasons i guess i guess for the most
part a lot of them wouldn't be on the
internet
you know so there you go in any case
with rittenhouse flight is
is not feasible in the current era it's
not
the 1970s you can't simply get a fake
cardboard driver's license my first
driver's license believe it or not was
not a laminated piece of plastic it was
just cardboard
typed on it which made it quite easy to
change for
underage drinking by the way wow but you
can't just get a fake license and go
live someplace for 20 or 30 years and
then a secret identity that doesn't
happen in the real world anymore
in any case it's not a general solution
because if that were to happen would
written house well the next case guess
what
you're not being released on bail
because now you're a flight risk
man this is creepy robert chapman says
home protection in new jersey is just
home alone traps just like the founding
fathers intended
that's fun there you go but if you set
booby traps you get trouble right
yes booby traps are not permissible
anywhere because of the
the concern with booby traps is oh and
this has been true through really all of
american history the concern is
it's not being controlled by a human
being so what happens if there's a fire
and a fireman comes in or a cop
is making a call or some innocent
intruder comes in you know a repairman
sent to the wrong address
then they get killed by your booby trap
when there was no justification for that
to happen
what about a tripwire not like to trip
someone like when when you when you
press when you pass it it just breaks
and there's a bang you can use
non-deadly booby traps that's not really
a concern they can
like electric fencing right okay things
of that sort
but like electric fencing that's not a
booby trap that's just a security
like what if you had you know it's a
physical deterrent to an intruder which
is what
what if you had a trip wire that when
you tripped it a taser fired at you
and it lasted for only like 10 seconds
then the question would be whether or
not the taser qualifies as deadly force
under that circumstance and you know
things like pepper spray and a taser
impact weapons clubs they they
they straddle the line between
non-deadly force and deadly force
depending on the manner of use so
in that case we talked about where the
suspect grabbed the cops taser was
running away
turned and shot at the cop with the
taser the cop shot him with a pistol and
killed him
if the cop is shooting a suspect with a
taser that's a non-deadly use of force
because there's no reason to believe the
cops going to continue to use force
after a person has been neutralized
when the reverse happens that's arguably
a deadly
use of force because there's good reason
to believe a criminal suspect will
continue to use force
on the officer take his gun and so forth
what if you put up a sign warning
you know 10 feet ahead is a trip wire
that would release pepper spray
like you you put a warning around it so
it might well be permissible i mean
pepper spray is really
nothing to be all that concerned about
the effects are so transitory
uh a taser first of all they mostly
don't work
i hate to tell everybody uh but when
they do work uh
they're so intense in their effect that
it's not hard to characterize it as
serious bodily injury which falls into
the deadly force bucket could you put a
sign that says
caution landmines on the property if
there are no landmines put up any signs
you want i guess it's arguably protected
by the first amendment oh yeah uh
don't be putting any land mines out
right what if what if purple said like
rabid goats on the property and they
will be unleashed
i'm just kidding people put up aware dog
signs right what's the message there the
message is if you come over
this fence there's a dog's gonna bite
your butt right yeah
or something else mike
jitsu said did ian just wake up from a
mushroom trip
lmao no i've been listening a lot this
episode
andrew's the man and it's not really
legal law and this stuff isn't really my
wheelhouse so
i'm more interested in listening yeah
man i mostly like the andrews the man
oh yeah yeah here we go wolfstar says
tim is mad at judges and calling them
cowards but he's also applauding all the
coward cops who are leaving their posts
what a
what a hypocritic well it would be
hypocrite
but uh yes the judge did not grant a
change of venue he could have right he
could have
granted change he could have and he he
didn't
grant a mistrial because the dude was
scared
okay fine okay maybe coward isn't the
right word maybe
groveling sniveling spineless loser is
the right word
stand up to the people who are
threatening you look him in the eyes
and say no because if every single
person just said no
they would have no power it's only
because of the spineless losers
they actually keep winning now as for
the police who are leaving
i'm saying what do you think is going to
happen when all of these cops leave
because they're told no one wants them
there
let the communities live the way they
choose without cops and let the judges
deal with their own protection
when they won't stand up for the police
or the ones supposed to be protecting
them
by the way i just want to put in as an
officer of the court that tim of course
is fully entitled to his opinion about
judges but it's not me disparaging the
judges
just for the record i'm just disparaging
the one judge i understand yeah i'm
actually i was
i was actually giving a lot of praise
throughout the trial for a variety of
reasons i just don't want to get a call
from the bar
oh yeah right it was when he um
when he said maxine waters you know what
you said may have well granted you
grounds for appeal right and i was like
how many times were you warned of this
that's gross and that was the least of
it i mean there are grounds for appeal
that are driven
not not just by the outlandish
outrageous things that a politician said
outside the courtroom
there's conduct really egregious
prosecutorial misconduct
that occurred inside the courtroom in
front of that
judge in front of the jury that were
grounds for a mistrial and he just
completely took a pass
yeah waffle sensei says the police are
serving the community
they are serving as sacrifices
conservatives do not adapt quickly
enough to to new systems
but they do prop up systems better than
anyone else that's why conservatives are
losing
falcon winter soldier though was a
cultural win
i don't know if you you watch any of
these shows disney plus
i don't have a lot of time for tv and
movies so so you know we were talking
about this the other day that falcon and
winter soldier
is anti-woke a lot of conservatives were
saying it was get well go broke disney's
woke but it's actually about a black
veteran
who takes up an american flag and beats
antifa with it
and so it's not totally it's it's fairly
middle of the road but
it is particularly anti-woke the bad
guys are antifa
and it's so it's so hilarious now
because in the middle of the show before
the conclusion happened and you realize
it's pro-america the left was laughing
and gloating about how you know white
privilege and patriarchy and toxic
masculinity or whatever
then the finale came and the guy they
thought was the bad guy was a good guy
and the bad guys uh this flag smashers
are just anti-fun now they're actually
writing articles where they're like why
is disney bashing antifa wow they're
making
antifa look like villains why are they
doing it yeah because maybe they are
i find it hilarious andrew irvin
says chairman mao was wrong about a
great many things but he was right when
he said that all political authority
comes from the barrel of a gun
i don't i don't necessarily think so i
think it's
not the barrel of a gun but uh i i think
a large portion is a fear of being
ostracized
a lot of people virtue signal political
points because they just don't want to
be booted out of
polite society as they call it well
political power certainly exerted
from the barrel of a gun i mean if you
don't obey the laws you might get a
ticket at first
but if you don't pay the ticket they'll
come back and if it keeps escalating
eventually you'll find yourself at the
barrel of a gun
the power itself at least in america
comes not from the barrel of a gun but
from the votes of the electorate and
when they do that wisely we end up with
good government and when they do it
poorly
well we end up where we are i don't know
if there's a way off this runaway train
you know you got a lot of dumb people
keep voting for the same thing for
tribal reasons
virtue signaling it feels good whatever
i don't know i mean to the extent
look there's been plenty of political
systems throughout human history that
have gone
into a collapse uh and generally what
happens during that period
is that the the people who can who have
the means and resources find ways to
protect themselves as much as possible
from the cataclysm of that collapse
and the people who bear the burden are
generally the people who lack the
resources to protect themselves but they
will
bear the burden make no mistake about
that all right
center sun says first super chat
watching for years
in my honest opinion give them what they
want abolish police
no state actors enforcing laws no
justice and corrupt system
buy home protection and move and move to
higher private security
look if you live in a rural area you
already need to consider
buying guns to defend yourself or
depending on if you have a big business
private security it's only in the big
cities
where people actually rely on police for
a lot of these things and i got to be
honest
it's probably only because the right to
keep and bear arms has been infringed
beyond all recognition in new york you
can't go buy a gun
it's so insanely difficult in new jersey
it's insanely difficult
so how are you supposed to rely on
yourself you can only rely on the police
so i'm like you know what what the worst
case scenario is if they abolish the
police
then i get i i retain my right to keep
and bear arms
you guys can do what you want to do in
your neighborhoods i'll do what i do
want to do in mine and
me and my community will just you know
watch each other's backs i suppose it's
not ideal
i'm not an anarchist or anything like
that a lot of anarchists like you know
i know one guy down to mexico he's all
about private security not a big fan of
private security as like the end-all be
already dealing with this problem
personal responsibility on the other
hand i think first and foremost you
should defend yourself your property
take responsibility for your own life
and not rely on cops to do it for you
well at the end of the day you're always
really your own first responder right
you're never going to be attacked while
a cop is standing next to you that's not
what happens
so at least at the start you better be
prepared to defend yourself
right i'll be honest i've carried a gun
my whole life for personal protection
when i'm on a trip like this my wife is
home with plenty of guns for personal
protection for her and our kids
we don't expect the police to be there
instantly maybe in 10 minutes
maybe in 15 minutes maybe longer
depending on what else is going on
in that intervening time if we're not
prepared to protect ourselves we're
literally
defenseless and that's not where i'd
want me or my family to be
what do they say when seconds matter the
cops are minutes away exactly right
still with the best of intentions by the
way i would point the intentions of the
cops they can't be there instantly that
you can make a phone call and community
police will be there
to protect you within 10 minutes is an
incredible boon
of modern society yeah all right we got
this from joel jamal he says
australian mp craig kelly announced he
is proposing legislation to combat
censorship
the legislation is based off florida's
bill that passed this comes after his
facebook page of 102 000 followers was
deleted by facebook for medical
misinformation
foreign interference wow
so what i love about this bill in
florida is that it could
entirely nuke uh wikipedia
so the bill says that if you're a
journalistic enterprise meaning that you
have at least 100 000 monthly active
users which is not that hard to come by
or you produce at least 100 hours of
content
and and have a viewership of over 100
million people per year so i think
they're trying to say it's a 100 million
active users might be defined
differently in the law it might be
bigger it might you might have to be the
new york times or something
however this means that many large
channels it means
my company for instance would be
protected under this and that would mean
we are allowed to write things and
wikipedia could not remove them
if that's the case this whole idea of
reliable sources they use where
conservative outlets are banned
but leftist outlets are considered
reliable is gone and wikipedia won't be
able to keep out
the opinions of individuals they won't
be able to ban them well in my opinion
losing wikipedia would not be losing
much i think they're the embodiment of
the dunning-kruger effect
you read wikipedia it all looks fine
until they write something
you know something about and then it's
obvious nonsense
my only expertise is use of force law
there's lots of stuff i might look at a
wikipedia that looks reasonable but when
i read what they write about any
use of force case it is utter nonsense
so as far as i'm concerned if they were
to disappear
it would be like the world's dumbest
encyclopedia
would um would it be more likely that
they just block florida ips
that's that no that that breaks oh you
mean like so that people in florida
can't use wikipedia
or facebook well texas has a similar law
i don't know if it's the exact same but
i don't think they'd be able to
someone in florida could be i guess they
could theoretically say
we don't provide service in florida so
we're not subject to its laws and people
could still use it then it'd be
interesting how they try to combat that
all right let's see william keller says
negative comment for tim
you are changing media and culture not
leaving it why can't cops stay and join
police
to change this from within it's an
example you don't quit because of
youtube
instead you make your own site i worked
for disney and i quit because it was
corrupt
the police are working for corrupt
departments they can remain in security
or they can find a better police
department
the good cops in these in these corrupt
cities can move to areas where they need
cops and they're not corrupt
and then there will be good not corrupt
cities with good cops and then there
will be major metropolitan urban centers
full of
bad cops corrupt cops and people
fighting and stabbing each other and
if you want to live there i don't tell
you the only difference is when you left
disney it didn't put the public at risk
if the you know the job wasn't like yeah
i did police forcing
but the problem is when i'm working when
you're working in journalism
you're supposed to be informing people
about what's going on so they can make
better decisions
the system was corrupt and not doing
that so i left to do something that was
better
the police officers working in these
departments are not able to do their
jobs right now
they're they're working for departments
where they're not actually able to solve
these problems because they'll be
demonized and sent to prison for it
so they need to leave and make something
different maybe i would suggest too that
the notion that police are going to
change the system from within
reflects the complete ignorance of how
police departments are actually
actually working or structured okay the
the street cops
are overseen by sergeants and above
sergeant you get to lieutenant various
commander ranks up to
the chief of police lieutenant on up are
effectively political appointments
so no street cop is going to do things
that are inconsistent with what his
political bosses are telling him or he
won't keep the job if he tries he'll be
fired
do lieutenants not quite as political as
a chief but guess what
they want to rise in the ranks they're
not going to rise in the ranks if they
conflict
with the policies and preferences of the
officers higher than them in rank
so you can't change the system from
within that's not realistic
all these people ultimately serve
political masters we say that politics
is downstream of culture
well police is downstream of the
politicians you elect if you want
different police
you'd have to do it like new york city
under giuliani where the boss of the
city
was able to affect changes in the police
department but if he hadn't wanted those
changes if he was opposed to those
changes
they would not have happened as we saw
when we got a different mayor who didn't
like
those stop and frisk type of policies
for example whatever you may
think of stop and frisk the point is
when the boss didn't want it anymore
it went away all right ew says mr branca
firearms instructor here
do you have materials that can be
purchased that would be good examples of
use of force for students in a
self-defense
ccl class videos etc well the first
thing i would say is take
advantage of the opportunity to get a
free book at law self defense dot com
slash timpool but we actually have an
entire instructor program certification
program
for firearms instructors uh we have lots
of dvd
online courses lots just uh we've been
doing this for
almost 25 years now folks so we have
tons of content you go to our website
lawselfdefense.com you can learn more
about all of that
here's one for you randy whalen says
randy wallen i took andrew's course in
2017.
he is a great resource for anyone who is
serious about lawful self-defense quote
carry a gun so you're hard to kill know
the law so you're hard to convict
that's our tagline thank you very much
sir i really appreciate that
alexander scarpecci says take tim cast
to florida there's plenty of rural
remote areas for you
i lived in florida once for a year in
the uh redlands just outside of miami
and it's hot you can't go outside ever
it's like 120
january and february you can go outside
nobody goes outside i'd go to the skate
park
nobody ever and it was a good park and
i'm like where's everybody it's like
nobody there
too hot but in january in february yeah
parker it was like 90 in february when i
went to miami
right and that's when you can go outside
i've lived in florida it's got its
strengths there's no question about it
but the main problem with florida is
that it's
well florida yeah yeah it is an issue
you know rhonda sandus i think is doing
a pretty good job but they uh i think in
miami there's a statue to the guy who
invented air conditioning there is
yeah yeah because people are like we can
live here now
but if you're if you're big on going to
the beach it's perfect you go to miami
beach you go on the beach it doesn't
matter how hot it is it's great
it's uh it's red but uh living out in
the redlands it was cool because the
storms are something else
they're beautiful the clouds and yeah
storms every afternoon every lifting
rain
all the time and they're amazing
watching this massive
you know massive downpour it was like
that in the in the rain forest in south
america
super cool and the rain only lasts for
like 15 minutes right it's not like the
northwest where it's always
wet it's like the rain comes sometimes
it's like a wall of rain approaching
you and it rains for 15 minutes and 15
minutes after that it's all dry again
i'd be like oh let's go skate oh wait
i think clouds are coming the sky's
clear and then all sudden clouds roll in
it rains and then we're like well just
wait a few minutes
and then once the clouds clear the sun
comes out it all dries up and it's all
ready to go did you get hit by a
hurricane while you were there
no almost man that's terrifying yeah so
there's hurricane shutters on the
building
on the windows and everything i'll pass
yeah
pass on the hurricane yeah so so ronda
sanchez is trying really hard to make
florida
more palatable because i love it but
it's exciting
yeah luke's down there luke luke down
there because of those laws
everybody if you haven't already smash
the like button
go over to timcast.com become a member
because we're gonna have an exclusive
members only segment coming up at about
11 p.m and make sure you follow this
show on instagram at tim cast irl and go
to facebook.com
castle and follow or like us there
because we put up smaller clips from the
show it's a whole lot of fun
and you can help us out by sharing those
clips on facebook and uh
you know whatever just go to pbs.com
it's even better you can follow me on
other platforms at tim cast my other
channels are youtube.comcast
and youtube.comcastnews this show is
live monday the friday at 8pm
so we will be back tomorrow is there uh
andrew anything else you wanted to shout
out
nope just remind people about the book
folks it's a brief
opportunity get the book for free law
self defense dot com slash
tim poole i'm sure you know how to spell
tim poole and uh tim thanks for having
me on it's been absolutely great it's
wonderful yeah it was really fun man
um you guys can also follow me at ian
crossland.net and i'm at ian crossland
amongst all socials apparently the
obsidian mirror i got for you tim
yesterday was
acrylic or something i don't know
plastic i hope it's real obsidian i
gotta look into it plastic we'll take it
but uh you can never just you can never
just believe things at face value
anymore
sad i feel like i learned so much
tonight thank you andrew for joining us
i'm sarah patchelids on twitter
and um yeah i'll talk to tim we'll see
you all over at timcast.com
and thanks for hanging out bye guys
you